have you always wanted to be a
cinematographer or did you want to be a
director instead uh cinematography came
to me kind of later and i feel like i
stumbled into it i um
directing was kind of always the goal i
you know i loved films and i loved uh
specifically atmosphere i was always
attracted to the atmosphere which
when i was a kid usually meant genre
horror sci-fi fantasy like the
fantastical
and i was
i think that's what drew me initially to
it is a totally different world
and then
over the years especially once i got
into
college and grad school more
specifically
i
you know i was making films with friends
i was writing a lot at the time also my
school was small so
doing film mixed with theater so plays
and all that and the more that i did
that uh i loved it but
everything was a little slow like you
sit by yourself your writing your
writing your writing you know directing
you have to organize a lot of things you
didn't really have producers at this
school
and
i started to
pay attention to cinematography
knowing my own thesis film was coming
soon and there was nobody in my school
that was very good shooter
and so i just started studying that and
other people started to ask me to shoot
their films
and so i started learning cinematography
really
by working on other people's films and
the immediate gratification of it became
very addictive
like directing it would you know took me
months to organize a short and whether i
was writing the script or getting it
from somebody else it still took time
but
you know cinematography it's just like
okay well let's light the scene now
let's shoot it now and that immediate
gratification
i think was a big
turnover for me i think i
just got addicted to knowing i can make
this happen right now whereas writing
which i still
very very rarely i still do some and i
do you know i still
hope to
find my way back to directing i miss
directing a lot i miss interacting with
actors not that i don't in my job now
but
in a slightly more intimate way perhaps
but yeah it really it was something that
i never aimed for but then it's it just
found its way to me
so it's yeah but i but now i love it
i've i've for a long time have been fond
of saying it's my second favorite job on
earth behind directing uh
but now
it's i don't know might be 1a1b because
i really i do love it and i love
the um
there's almost like your
responsibilities are a bit
lessened i hate to put it that way but
there's i watch some directors and
they're being flooded with emails and
calls and texts and all through the
night and for me for the most part
assuming my prep went well enough
i
the load is a little less and i feel
like my quality of life is pretty good
which is sort of a sad
way to say why you've leaned into
something but
i have found it to be true so yeah well
some people know some people the idea of
one thing sounds great but then when you
actually look at what the duties are
then maybe you know some people are more
visual some people are more you know
this they're better not even speaking
they just know intuitively what they
want yeah no that's a that's a good
point there is a lot of
i've always loved cameras just i've
always been fascinated by cameras and so
as a kid i loved picking cameras up and
so
there is something to be said but
perhaps i just it took me a while to
just find my way to cinematography
because of that because i just cameras
were always a big part of it and i've
always been a visual learner and all of
those things so so maybe it was
inevitable that i would find my way to
cinematography for sure
were you good at magic like i could see
you being like a magic like person
that's you know uh
ventriloquism if that counts i was i was
into ventriloquism for a very small
amount of time but um
yeah i mean you know
i did originally what everybody thought
i was going to do was draw i used to
draw like crazy really into comic books
and so i just everything i would just
draw draw draw and then that turned into
writing
for a long time
and
but i but it was really even with
writing my writing was very visually
oriented if that makes sense very
descriptive in terms of again atmosphere
i think there's something about
atmosphere that i i have a mini
obsession with just creating the the
texture of
of the of a world is something that i
love deeply and i think with
cinematography i get to do more of that
and what was your thesis film about
uh like it was a dark
it was like a it was very much inspired
by grim fairy tales so my thesis was uh
a young girl whose
mother has passed uh at the very
beginning of the film we see her only as
a as a corpse
and her father turns to drinking
and
the little girl gets
obsessed with trying to fix her mom and
so it begins if i remember correctly her
dad says something like
to the effect of oh her her heart is
is broken it's so she's not around now
and the little girl decides oh if i can
get her a new heart
then we'll have a new
you know she'll be fine and so she goes
around and it takes place in like
a sort of fantastical
16th century uh and she goes around and
starts collecting body parts from
various folks so it's like a little
bloody there's a storybook like a
literal storybook i had an artist friend
of mine chris henry draw this whole
thing and so it's it opens with once
upon a time
opens up and
filmed it in the redwoods in northern
california
which was beautiful great you know
production value
and yeah it was a dark
dark horror comedy i suppose
yeah i
you know
i don't think i would be able to sit and
watch it now without clawing my own eyes
out but it was uh
i was very happy with the attempt i'm
glad i tried something strange i think
that's up my alley strange has always
been up my alley
i wouldn't know anything about it
[Laughter]
what was your first camera oh first
cameras well
so when i was
boy i'm gonna say 16-ish
i dug up my grandfather's old super 8
camera
and so i
started shooting with super 8 but having
no idea what i was doing i didn't know
what any of the settings meant
and i just it's it's thinking back on it
it's sort of amazing that some of it was
exposed i mean i had no idea what i was
just setting it in the middle and so i
did get a few rolls back that were just
black
but uh for the most part everything came
out pretty exposed and so i shot some
short films on super 8 for a little
while
and then uh
and then i think the the my first
camera this would have been
the tail end of college it was a
panasonic dvx 100 which was
you know the first
it was minidv which is
maybe
the worst format in a lot of ways in
terms of actual qual image quality but
it shot 24 frames per second it had uh i
mean really i shot a lot with it it was
a lot of sketch comedy at the time that
i was i've always been very into comedy
uh
and
yeah that camera felt like a
a step even though i did i don't know
that i ever got paid for a single job
with it i shot a lot with it which was
great
and then you know from there some years
later the panasonic hvx 100 i think the
the hd basically digital version of that
i never owned that but i worked at a
company
that had one and they let me use it
whenever so
yeah i think those were those were kind
of the big camera steps
for me and then with many others in
between a 70 a 5d a7s and eventually an
alexa mini
do you still have the mini dv tapes
no
unfortunately you know it's a bummer i
uh about
let's see this would have been 11 years
ago
my house that was renting uh burned down
in one of the la at the time the biggest
fire in la and i lost all of my films i
lost all my writing all my art i used to
you know draw and
it was it was it still still kind of
stings but
you know truthfully it was a big um
reset button i i
it's it has helped me with uh attachment
and having a lack of it uh it was
the year after my house burned down i
just kind of lived on the road for a
year i could fit everything i owned in a
backpack and so i slept on couches i
flew out to hawaii and slept on my
buddy's hotel room while we were working
on a movie out there like it was
my life was a bit of an adventure which
i think was
good i think it was it was an
interesting life for a time uh but
the at the sacrifice of losing
you know all basically everything i had
created up until 30 years old
essentially
was this the station fire yeah the
station fire yeah i remember it yeah
yeah it was it was yeah it was a
strange time strange time it's it's
funny to think that that's so long ago
because it does feel
so uh
relevant to my life like it really i'm
it's it's altered some of my
way of approaching things and
and purchases feel strange to me still
furniture and i like owning things still
feels a little weird a little ptsd i
think but
you know i i
my life has been good since then so it's
i just one of the stepping stones i
guess who knows
aside from it you losing all these
things and and that being
the horrible like negative side and
losing in a sense your parts of yourself
really went down in that fire do you
think it showed you how temporary things
are and you looked at things in a new
light in a positive way that way yeah i
would for sure say the silver lining of
losing everything is that you
the idea of impermanence becomes a lot
easier to grasp
and i for sure
it's
the impermanence of everything life
health i mean
friendships you know
you just never i think i take some of
those things less for granted now
perhaps i hope i don't know uh
and i do wonder you know 20 years from
now
what will the scars of that look like
will they still be there will i you know
i don't know i moved into a house a year
ago
after living in someone else's house
for basically 10 years i had like a wing
of a house to myself and
when i moved into my place last year i
owned nothing i had no bed i didn't have
a chair a desk i had nothing and so
11 years well 10 years i guess at the
time after the fire was the first time
that i was like okay i gotta purchase
some things
and it felt it still feels odd i can
feel the weight of those things i liked
i liked the idea that it you know any
particular morning not to say i would do
this necessarily but that i could just
kind of pack up everything into my car
and be on my way and that's everything
that's all i need so
yeah i don't know so it's strange i
think i'm still
processing all of it you know in terms
of its ultimate lessons
no things do own you it's true yeah
yeah they have a weight for sure yeah
when did you realize you were obsessed
with cinematography
um
okay so i was obsessed with movies very
young
and i'm trying to think of when i became
conscious of cinematography even as a
job or a
as a position on
to be honest i don't know i think i even
probably ahead of cinematography is i
think i was stricken by production
design not realizing that it was
production design because again i was so
i've always been so attracted to the
atmosphere being built and so often
uh the production design is doing
especially if you're leaning into
something fantastical you know like the
movie legend was something i loved as a
kid and the sets are amazing and i think
that was the first time i realized oh
somebody's
doing this somebody's making this happen
but cinematography
i mean i
i would think somewhere in college and i
think it's specifically
that it was the camera side of things
since i had always enjoyed photography
and just cameras in general
i realized somebody on set is touching a
camera and so i think that was the first
inkling but to be honest i don't it
feels so
gradual my cinematography and i
discovering each other it almost feels
like you know it's one like a like a
romance where you're like oh we were 12
years old and we used to play at the
beach together and then
you know over the years you start to be
like hey
she's kind of hot or whatever and
those little
flirtations like it just didn't occur to
me and then all of a sudden one day
you're like oh i think i'm in love like
this is
it's a thing so
i
i think for me
in college when people started asking me
to shoot their films
i think was so being a cinematographer i
think was the first time i started to
realize like oh i really love this
because even with films that i loved
i was while i was aware of
cinematographers
it
i never thought of it as a job
for myself somehow so i don't know it's
sort of strange to think now
because that's what my life is kind of
built around is cinematography in a lot
of ways i mean all the things i
read about and find myself fascinated by
and i
i'm always paying attention to cameras
and lights and and light in general you
know i'm so conscious of all these
things now but
yeah i really don't even remember where
cinematography and i found each other
strange
do you think because you know you went
to humboldt state you got like a double
graduate degree yeah yeah yeah
yeah i got two masters up there and and
again it was so one was in screenwriting
and one was in film production and
because our school was so small it was
really geared more toward a documentary
and experimental film
and i
it really
feels like a stroke of luck in timing
when i was there there were
other students who joined at the same
time a bunch of talented writers
directors
and all of us
were geared toward narrative and because
the department was so small we almost
created a path together whereas normally
it was documentary or experimental
we kind of forged our own path of
narrative you know with the professors
as well
[Music]
and
you know the experimental element really
found it's i really loved experimental
film and discovering like maya darren
and stan brackets these like
you know gods of experimental film but
most people haven't heard of them and i
just loved it there were these weird
esoteric bizarre films and i you know i
made
films where i was scratching the
emulsion and coloring that and you know
conforming by hand and having physical
negatives in my hand
it i i really dug that and i think it's
had a real effect on my approach to
cinematography for sure there's
something very tactile that i lean into
i like i like the things that i shoot to
have a
a tactile almost messiness to them it's
it's interesting and i assume that's
where that came from but i don't really
know
do you ever question had you gone to
another college
maybe they would they would have been
more regimented like did you have a lot
of freedom there yeah we had a ton of
freedom in our program and i
the first year that i went there it was
a fluke i went uh before i went to grad
school when i was in undergrad i did
undergrad in massachusetts umass amherst
and they had a domestic exchange program
which i had no i'd never even heard of
and the day i walked into their office i
just asked like hey how does this work
and
they gave me a bunch of brochures and
they were like oh here's a book of all
the schools that we have a partnership
with you could go to any of these
schools in theory
and so i went to the library i took it
right then went to the library sat with
it for a couple hours and i was looking
for a place that had film classes that
was not in a city and that was near the
ocean and that was it and it was like
three or four schools that fit that and
humboldt which i had never heard of at
the time
the deadline for that was like that day
or that week
and so i went back i had my little list
and i went back to the
the woman who gave me the brochures and
i asked like how strict are these
deadlines like if i wanted to apply to
humboldt could i still do it she's like
you know i'm not sure let me check and
she goes into her office and she gets on
the phone and she's on the phone for a
while
and she finally comes out and it's like
okay you're enrolled for the fall
and i was just like well i didn't even
know if i wanted to do any of this
but i just
was like screw it and i just went i went
across the country i went to that school
and that year
changed my life i mean dramatically it
was really
i had been at umass they didn't have a
film program so i was taking
film theory classes they had a
sprinkling of those
but no production and i went out to that
school and i wrote plays that got
produced i was acting in plays i was
making films hand over fists like we
were all it was just this like i
mentioned there was there were these
other students that were
hungry in the same way i was
and i just spent a year
producing content constantly
and
because the department was small
we
just kind of
forged our own path
and i think uh to to your initial
question if i had gone to a school with
more structure
i don't know how that would have gone i
don't know structure and i have not
always been the best of friends so i do
wonder what would have happened and i
you know i used to be a painfully shy
person and that year in humble really
opened me up and i do wonder if i went
to a school with more rules
maybe i never would have opened up i
don't know and i had writing teachers
and film teachers that
i bonded with and
you know the classes were smaller so you
have the opportunity to bond and
yeah i mean i it all it was i remember
that was the first time in my life where
i started to believe in fate i was just
like you know i stumbled into the school
and it changed my life
i think inarguably for the better
personality wise work ethic wise
opening my eyes up to
different approaches to art and
experimental film and all these things
that
i just
i hadn't planned on any of them and then
all of them really just sunk their hooks
into me so
i've heard it's a magical place up there
not just the way it looks but also the
mindset yes for sure yeah and you know
i'm i'm more of i mean i've been in la
now for 15 years but
i uh i'm a nature boy i'm a country boy
so up there you know i worked really
hard but then my breaks i'd go off into
the most beautiful forests in the world
to take a walk and all that and i think
that really nurtured me and and you know
helped my soul a bit for sure
what's the hardest part of being a
cinematographer
the hardest part of being a
is
probably
well i reserve the right to take this
back uh and but i think
well in general i think
time is always the enemy so it's trying
to manage time
i think that's uh
a big part of filmmaking and probably
life too is just just time
you can never make more time you can
make everything else but you can't make
more time
and as a cinematographer you're always
going to be torn
between
ooh i could add another light or we
could bring in some negative you can
always tweak an image
but
the more time you give something now the
less time you'll have
in the evening for the scene that's
later so you're constantly
compromising uh so i it's so it's either
the battle with time or the battle with
ego i really i'm the more i work the
more i realize ego
really takes up a lot of space on set
and it's not and i don't mean
just other people's ego though i do also
mean that but really
your own especially as cinematographer
hierarchy gets very tricky you know on
ice i've always been a feature film nerd
and it's almost easy
on a feature the director's the boss
generally like that's so it's almost a
cleaner thing but the more tv i've been
doing
it's my job to
make sure that there are visual through
lines and sometimes you have a director
who comes in and maybe wants to do
something that isn't in the language of
the show
and you try to balance
like okay i want to give the director
what they want but i have to also make
sure that the show runner that we're or
whoever the producer whoever might be
the creative through line that they're
getting what they need and that i'm also
making sure that we're not getting off
track too far
and
finding
the places to to
curb my own ego when there are other
people telling me
that we need to do something that feels
wrong
or
or maybe just i don't like you know
whatever that is and and
trying to quiet
my ego so that i can be logical about
something like okay is this just because
i want my idea to be right or is this
actually
affecting the what we're working on
right now like how much
is ego versus you know
something that's actually for the show
and i've been lucky that over the last
four years i've been working on a lot of
series and just really going going going
and it's helped me i think
i think if i had done some of the jobs
i've had in the last year if i had done
them five years ago
i think i would have done a
significantly poorer job
because
just because of my own ego which i hate
to say but i
it's something that i've noticed more
and more is
keeping my own mind quiet while on set
and learning to listen as opposed to
talk and get all my ideas out it's
really trying to
yeah
navigation of ego i guess so time or ego
it's one of those two as the probably
the trickiest part of my job
i think
and this is going to go back to humboldt
state again but do you think in some
ways um it was so supportive that when
you came to another place that was maybe
more competitive
that it was more difficult to navigate
or that's just that's my ego
yeah right no i think it's it's
interesting because going back to humble
and my grad school this is this is the
one of my arguments for film school
actually is
to
to be in a place where you can fail
constantly like like it's okay it's not
only okay you should fail you should
swing for the fences and
fall on your butt like it's i think
that's important and
it also because my program was small and
you were doing everything it did give me
confidence for sure so i had you know
it's easy to be a big fish in a small
pond
but when you move to los angeles like
nobody cares and i you know i was i was
shooting i was like one of the only
people that anyone would call to shoot a
short up and humble and then i came to
l.a and it took me years before i could
get anybody to let me shoot anything for
free i was gripping and then gaffing for
a while and
it definitely
uh yeah i mean i guess that was also
tricky for my ego
but again same thing i worked with with
the with a gentleman hollywood heard
who's his name uh i don't even remember
what his real first name was but he we
all called him hollywood and he was a an
older gaffer
and he
taught me a lot he and a big part of it
was keep it taught me to keep my mouth
shut because i
you know i was used to being
somebody who had opinions that people
would listen to on tiny tiny little sets
and he gave me my first work in los
angeles on you know low budget features
that kind of thing
and
realizing like i'm a small cog
in a very large machine
and
watching people make mistakes that i
some of them i could foresee was very
frustrating he'd be like oh the sun is
by the time this track is laid down the
sun will be behind those trees like i
can see it and they're like no this
isn't your job you could you don't tell
them how to
and then i'd watch that happen so so it
was hard
to
learn to shut up
uh but also
really good for me you know that's
i like to when i'm on set i encourage my
crew to give me ideas i love gathering
ideas it doesn't mean i'll take them but
i'm very open i love collaboration but i
also
you know i do my work and so if
something doesn't fit aesthetically or
tonally it's easy for me to
just be like
i don't think we're going to do this in
on steadicam i think that that doesn't
quite you know whatever so i i think
just
yeah i i don't know i guess it's a dance
because in in humboldt uh my ego
probably got inflated and then it got
beat down coming to los angeles and
and now i don't i guess i don't know
where i sit with with my own ego always
working on it meditating every day
and which is a habit i picked up
because of film i i was on a
series in albania
that was so stressful i almost had a
nervous breakdown like i had a really
tough time and the director
meditated every day at lunch and out of
pure desperation
uh just to try and do anything i started
meditating
and now i never i haven't missed a day
of uh a meditation before a day of
shooting in
probably four years i've been yeah
so that's that's helped yeah
and for how long a period of time do you
meditate so i meditate it's pretty quick
i do ten my rhythm now is when i'm
working i wake up i do my you know
morning stuff at home and i get to set
early and i meditate for 10 or 15
minutes in my car
and then i get out i have a little
breakfast and and then start the day so
it's 10 10 15 minutes every morning
before i walk onto set but always parked
right near it
and what happens if you're you're trying
to meditate but then there's this little
oh did i bring that oh didn't i did i
remember
oh sh what if there's like this nagging
voice about what you're supposed to do
yeah i mean i i have i've been
meditating for four years and i've
probably i could probably count on one
hand the number of times where a little
voice wasn't talking to me so it's just
part of it it's part of the process and
that's fine and you know i can always
deal with it after my 10-15 minutes is
up so whatever it is
uh
it it definitely comes in and out but
i'll just deal with it afterwards
usually usually the 10-minute span
doesn't affect anything so yeah i just
let those thoughts go as best i can
what would your advice be for let's say
a young person who comes to a
competitive set it doesn't have to just
be la
and what i've seen with competitive
environments is there's a lot of
unwritten rules and you'll never you
learn trial by fight you know you're
gonna find out that oh that wasn't okay
but you didn't know it so what would
your advice be and they're they're just
someone that has good intentions they're
not trying to
climb up they just think that that's the
way to do it
but they're not sure this is like an un
sort of uncharted territory yeah i mean
being on set is
tricky for sure for everyone and if
you're newer um i think
i mean really i think the biggest piece
of advice for anybody who wants to work
really in any capacity uh on a film set
is
be kind and be humble like it doesn't
like if you're if you're right and
you're witnessing people be wrong
fine like that you don't need to express
that like it's okay
to just
swallow some of your comments and just
be i mean really film work especially
narrative like features tv
longer shorts they're exhausting they're
so time i mean commerci everything
and
you know once you get to our 14 on day
everybody's exhausted everybody's
stressed people miss their families it's
it's
a very
film work is very difficult
and
the people who you surround yourself by
or who you are surrounded by
affect
everything your mood your ability to
think and if somebody is challenging you
constantly even if they're right
it it beats you down and you only have
so much energy i think of it sometimes
like a battery just being drained and if
you have to spend five percent of your
battery
dealing with a personality
like then that's removing five percent
from something else and
the people who seem to get hired
more
are people who are pleasant to work with
and
i think
that's something that surprised me a lot
about los angeles but it also it just
delights me i never thought that
you know being kind would help your
career
but it makes perfect sense now that i'm
on set and i realize how exhausting
people are
ever everybody myself included we're all
exhausting everybody needs
something from you know whether we need
affirmations or whatever it is
we're draining we're exhausting as a
species so
when somebody is easy
and still does their job it's a magical
combination and so i really i think
everybody's eager especially when you're
young and you're new you're eager to get
ahead or i want like this or you know or
just chasing money or whatever it is
i think
slowing down and just being in the room
and
yeah learning to read a room
that's the other thing so i think being
kind and learning to read a room when
it's tense
you know maybe be a little more quiet
when everybody's in a good mood like
that's great jive along with it but
being reading the room knowing when to
be quiet which is just most of the time
i think that stuff all helps but really
being kind being humble i think goes it
takes you far in life i think
i'll check back in 20 years
that's great wow i like that story so
the guy he he was you said a gaffer or
he was like a and he's he was
kind of saw you and said like don't
don't do this and don't do that yeah he
really he he would get in my ear and
he's sort of you know he's a big
personality so you know i don't know
i don't know
i'd be i'd be curious i haven't seen him
in 15 years probably so i'd be curious
to see how he's doing now but for me
i got frustrated
seeing people with way more experience
than me so i i thought i knew better
uh
and he was just like hey that's not your
job like that's a big part of it is
i had come partially coming from such a
small school and small town you show up
on set you're gonna do a little of
everything sound lighting crafty like
you you're gonna get your fingers in
every aspect of it
and
being on sets they were still you know
small movies but
you have your lane and
i would offer to help other departments
and if they wanted help great and if
they didn't
that's also great like it
so i think
learning your position and knowing you
can't do everything uh unless you know
you are so there are some directors who
are great at everything there are very
few of them but there are some who are
just very knowledgeable but that also
tends to lead to micromanagement and
people don't tend to enjoy that you know
people want to feel like collaborators
they want to feel like they have
some input on on you know have their
fingerprints on a project in one way or
another so
yeah i think i think just
learning to not
just do your job and with a smile on
your face if you can manage it so yeah
i'm not sure if you're okay talking
about this but did you go through a
period of time where you were not able
to pay your bills being a
cinematographer oh yeah no i'm happy to
discuss that yeah yeah for sure okay
yeah i
so i've been in los angeles for 15 years
15 something like that and i've was i've
been broke for
probably 11 of them 10 something like
that like
problematically broke for
you know five six years and i feel very
lucky this is this is one of the things
that i i'm always very thankful for is
i always knew i wanted to be involved in
filmmaking or at least from a very young
age i
i didn't know if it was realistic my
mother wanted me to be a doctor my whole
family's doctors except for me uh
but i just i was so
i just loved it so much filmmaking the
idea of it and any little taste i got
that i was can i slept in my car my last
semester of undergrad i slept in my car
i went to the gym in the morning to
shower like it was it never felt and it
kind of felt romantic i never felt
uh
like i was sacrificing
even though i guess i was it didn't feel
that way because i was pursuing this
kind of weird dream and
it always
and money i will say
you know it's tricky if you if you're
raising a family and all that but i
for me
it has always served me well
to ignore
money in
the jobs i pursue and all that i have
friends who are
um who are doing well in let's say the
commercial world or the corporate world
in terms of filmmaking and they
they will tell me that they're envious
of me because i you know i've shot some
features and tv shows but then something
will come their way
some you know low budget feature and
they'll say no because the pay is no
good
but then they get frustrated that
they're not getting a feature
but they just want it and narrative pays
worse than commercials
that's generally the rule and
that's for me ignoring the money and
just chasing the project or the director
has served me very well some of the best
some of the jobs you know i think about
the last show i shot was penn 15 a hulu
series and that director we've worked
together on multiple projects we shot a
series before for cso which is a defunct
uh
streaming service
and
we did we shot a web series for i think
it was like
three days four days of shooting i think
i got paid 100 bucks
and i worked my butt off and still to
this day it's one of my favorite things
that i shot uh i believe for him he got
his his
manager from that
he he had a screening it went very well
he it kind of kicked things off for him
and you know at the time when he asked
me to do it i did hesitate i was like oh
that barely pays like it's barely paying
me anything and then i did it and i
loved it i loved the project i love
everybody involved
a lot of those people are doing well
these days and it's
a piece of my community in los angeles
came from that tiny web series
so for me
and you know we'll see now we're we're
in a pandemic as we speak and i haven't
worked in months and
i have
i was okay with it for a time and now
the anxiety's starting to creep in but
you know i've been freelance for 15
years and i'm used to all manner of ups
and downs and i keep my overhead low
so that i i don't have to chase uh
money i guess yeah
were you actively looking for jobs or
because so much of the film industry
just completely shut down
so yeah now i'm i
at this point
i have the only thing that i've done to
be proactive really is
i have i can't i'm not very active with
social media
and
i realize that for my job i probably
should i should make that a higher
priority and i do have friends who are
really good with instagram specifically
and
i realize that it's
at least potent has the potential to be
a good tool for finding work and so
i am now trying to treat it a little
more seriously
and
trying to create posts that i would like
to see like maybe a little educational
or a behind the scenes or how did you
light this or why is the the color
palette this that kind of thing so i'm
trying to now
just so i feel
proactive because i don't really know
what else i can be doing right now to
find work
uh i've built a decent network over the
years i have a
reputation
that i am proud of
but
when people aren't calling
i'm genuinely not sure of what one does
and i'm learning i'm trying to figure it
out i'm talking to different people and
seeing what
what they think and
you know just kind of trusting that
something will come and
you know the the last show i shot did
well in terms of it's its reviews and
and fine finding an audience
uh so i'm hoping that that you know
might might put my name on some lists
but the truth is
so much of this is a crapshoot i really
don't know
how to find work even when you know a
decade ago i woke up every day and i
would start on craigslist and
mandy was
a thing and but
i was trying to do that the other day i
was like i'm curious are people posting
jobs no during all this uh but i've
never been sure how to
find work i've nev
it's never made sense to me uh but i
have been okay at building relationships
and not in an aggressive networking way
i don't think it's mostly
i'm a big film nerd and i end up bonding
with people who are also film nerds and
the directors who i've bonded with it
tends to be
somebody who i met somewhere
and we just got to talking about some
movie that we saw and then it snowballs
you're like oh have you ever seen this
movie and this and just the excitement
of it and and i think that's one of the
arguments for being in los angeles
is you are around
other people who are chasing the same
dream
and
a lot of them you'll find people who are
nerdy in the same way you're nerdy and
then you bond and then going back to
what i was saying earlier about
how you are on set
that often starts
way before it you know it could be in a
job interview but ideally it's a social
setting you're meeting a friend of a
friend of a friend sat somebody's
birthday and you're like oh i really
liked that person i was like what do
they do oh cinematographer well you know
we have this thing coming up and i think
that's how a lot of
los angeles connections get made and i
think that was the
downside of going to such a small school
is it really didn't i came to la with
zero connections and i think people who
go to usc for instance
which is way more expensive
so it has that downside but i think you
are meeting people who are going to be
in the industry
uh for the next decade at least and i
think that gives you a real head start
in a lot of ways and now i don't know in
terms of film education and the debt or
all that i don't know pros and cons but
uh
i think yeah meeting p which again in a
pandemic is tricky i have no idea how
i'm gonna meet people but you know there
are film
groups that are meeting on zoom and i
should maybe try to be more proactive
about that but yeah and you know doing
something like this
who knows who knows who will who will
see the interview and be like hey that
guy yeah
yeah exactly i want to meditate in my
car with you yeah exactly right so yeah
you never know
but yeah yeah i i i've never been good
at figuring out how to get work how to
summon work
it's definitely one of the we i'm i'm
fond of saying this but i think it's
true i'm i'm bad at the business side of
the business
so
i see a lot of true artists are that way
yeah i've definitely i know a lot i have
a lot of musician friends and
some of the best ones are terrible at
every other part of life you know yeah
so yeah i don't know what one does with
that but
yeah
you just kind of trust and and
i think i think really the fact that
i've been freelance for so long and i've
gone through such lean times
uh
it
prepares you for future lean times so
yeah so so far i feel okay i think i
think i told myself i'm allowed to get
anxious
next march
one year at the one year anniversary if
i still have no work then i'm allowed to
start getting a little anxious 2021 2021
yeah so
so i'm a little ahead of schedule i got
anxious for the first time a week or two
ago so i've gotta that's not part of the
deal so i've gotta i've gotta
keep my because i know as soon as i end
up on a set and i'm on week four and i'm
exhausted i'll be like ah
remember when it was a pandemic and i
could just sleep whenever i wanted so
i'll be wishing for this downtime
yeah
right well i mean if we look if we go
back to 1918
for was it the the spanish family yeah
so i mean what was that two years if we
look at the chart
i'm not exactly sure but yeah and if you
think about
medical advances are far greater now but
then there's the whole thing does
anybody want to take a vaccine right we
don't you know we won't go down that
slipper state but
so i know that's the thing when you're
talking about 2009 and and station fire
and all that that was there was a
recession and that was tragic and we
thought we'd probably never see anything
like that in our lifetime again and now
you add a bad economy to
a communicable disease sorry i can't
even say the word but
that
you know is is so it's it's there's new
variables that you've never really been
in this
yeah
yeah no and you know i will say i mean
i think that's always on the table i
think you know life is change and if as
soon as you think you have stability and
a predictability to your life i think
something's gonna shake it up that's
something and that could be the fire
speaking uh but that's that's how
certainly i try not to take anything for
granted or assume
i think also you know the film industry
in and of itself like the number of
projects that i was getting ready to
shoot that then just fell through i mean
it's innumerable the i was supposed to
be shooting a feature this summer that i
was really excited about i had three
features lined up this year and poof you
know
uh but i i've just in normal times
that still happens so i think
being prepared for instability uh in
this industry is really important and
you know and
weighing if that's worth it you know i
i'm
lucky i don't have a wife and kids
and so my anxiety any anxiety that
arises is just for me
i would imagine for somebody with a
family
you have to provide for like that's
that's
i don't see how that couldn't raise your
stress so
you know it's a uh
our industry is pretty cruel it's it
chews you up it spits you out um there's
always somebody
behind you in line so
i you know i don't know i think that's
why you you really gotta love it because
otherwise
i do not recommend getting into this
industry
uh it's and but i'm lucky because i do
love it i love it i love it very
purely so now we'll see how long that
lasts i'm sure one morning i'll wake up
and be like
i'm going to go see if there's work at
the gas station like
who knows or you could you said you love
like ventriloquism and things like that
you never know you might
make a line of of these puppets or what
i mean
there's new things that could happen
that sometimes we don't even know what
our interests are it's true yeah you
never know and again and i try to be
open to all those things to life is
change and it's all an adventure and
you know tick tock who knows how much
time you got left so i think being open
to any any other experiences any other
uh
paths that reveal themselves in life
like
i don't know take it
why not what the heck so yeah i'm always
open to
to anything that might come down the
pike if i respond to it
that's that's all i need and then i'll
follow that
when you look back at those times when
you know you were trying to find work
and and they were lean times did you
lose faith in yourself did you ever say
you know what i should have i should
have done pre-med hmm
yeah i think in my leaner times
there were certainly doubts that came up
like is this plausible i mean the truth
is i still wonder is can i do this for
another
10 20 30 40 years and i genuinely don't
know um
so
i think there have there have been
doubts in terms of
is this
is this a a lifestyle
that i want to continue pursuing uh i've
i that is probably the bigger one i had
a year um
2017 which was my first really busy year
and i shot
i
i can't remember it was like
40 episodes of half hour various shows
half hour tv it was just i went from one
show to the next to the next i spent six
or seven months
in
other states shooting and it was good uh
obviously to be shooting
i was so exhausted by the end of the
year
that i felt really burnt out and i got
freaked out that i was like oh no like
can i not do this anymore and i and i it
took me two months to recover just
sleeping basically for two months i seen
friends for the first time in a year
and
it it was the first time where i got
scared of what
can happen in this industry on the flip
side i was used to being broke and not
having work and that brought its own
anxiety and then
doing
13 hour days for a full year
just ground me down
mentally and physically
and then
and so now i
when i have the luxury of of choosing uh
jobs i now pay more attention who am i
working with is this really something
that i feel a pull toward
and trying to weigh
you know pros and cons of everything
because it's
yeah i i really don't know i mean i
really have
i am scared of this industry i've
watched it take
more talented people and spit them out
and turn them bitter and that's
something i'm really worried about i
don't i don't want that to be the case
with me i want to make sure that i still
love what i'm doing for as long as
possible
and you know part of that is meditation
making sure i know that so going for
evening walks for me is like a huge
thing it calms me down and all that so
uh when i'm working on set on on a show
i have a lot of strict rules i have
dietary rules and sleep rules that i
follow really closely because of that
one year i just it was so intense
that it freaked me out and now you know
and built so you're taking that
experience and combining it with years
of being broke
and having doubts but always still just
kind of okay just keep working on your
craft and
hope i guess hope that something works
out but yeah i don't know it's it's
really it's it's a
it's all scary when i really think about
this industry
it's
it's a tough it's a tough one to feel
good about unfortunately and i'm hoping
you know who knows this pandemic maybe
i'm hoping it'll turn into i've heard
some shows are switching to french hours
which means instead of a 12 and a half
hour day with a half hour lunch in the
middle
is you
you work for 10 hours straight you don't
stop for lunch it's a walking lunch
and i would love that to go home two
hours earlier
is
definitely worth not sitting down for a
half hour for lunch
uh
but it helps your immune system you know
we're learning more about
what lack of sleep does to your body and
it's not good
so i do hope that
you know be it a certain director or a
certain studio or whatever it is
that quality of life maybe could move up
the list in terms of priorities i think
that'd be lovely
i don't have a lot of faith in that
happening but
i do hope that there's a way to be doing
this into my well into my 70s
and feel like i'm still taking care of
my life
i don't know if that's possible but
you know one can dream
we interviewed a gentleman who said that
a lot of hollywood work is like temp
work you're kind of swinging from one
job to another
and it's never where you're really
landing in one spot yeah but on the flip
side you could say well there's a lot of
people that had corporate jobs that they
were just
given a severance package and pushed out
the door yeah so nothing is really
guaranteed
absolutely yeah no it's it's it's true i
mean
i think
the nature of most film work or at least
the film work
that i do um
is
there just isn't stability the they're
just and there won't be you know i i
remember years ago this would have been
this was probably 20 years ago
i saw an interview with kevin bacon
and he was
is still i believe married to kira
sedgwick and
it was them and kevin bacon you know has
been around since i was a kid
and he said that after every project
when it goes quiet
he gets very nervous he's like oh no am
i ever going to work again. and i
remember that sticking out to me like
wait kevin bacon
is worried about getting work
and
now that i've been in the industry for a
little while i'm like oh right like
there's just no you have no idea
if you will be even if you're on top of
the world
two years from now
you know maybe nobody remembers your
name or you shoot a project that bombs
or you know whatever it is it's
it's such a competitive
world and i think
you know i i
i don't think it's a good industry to
base your life on if you want to build a
healthy family and i hate saying that
because it is an industry i love so
dearly
but
having a relationship
when you're gone you know 80 hours a
week and you come home you're exhausted
uh
i don't know
you you have to have a special
partnership to make that work i think
it's very
uh stressful on all your relationships
romantic friend all that uh and i you
know
i don't know i mean
i think mostly i like to
put that out there it doesn't nothing is
good or bad it just is you know like and
that's just a fact of our industry
and i think it's important for people to
realize that because it's
i think there are a lot of romantic
ideas going in
but
the reality of it is and especially now
you know i don't know will movie
theaters open back up period i'm sure
they're going to open up in some
capacity but
you know our world is changing and
streaming is now huge i mean there are
more tv shows being made than ever in
the history
of
hollywood
but
there are no more residuals you know
almost entirely gone
and that's how a lot of writers and
directors and actors maintained a career
is that you were getting residuals from
old projects but they don't have
residuals on any of the streaming
services
so the future of our industry is very
uncertain uh
but the flip side is is if you
if you just look at the the art of
making and you know between youtube and
all these shows on netflix and hulu and
amazon and all these there's more work
and creation being done than ever before
it's just the money is the trick
but money is always the trick i suppose
sure
but when you look at your imdb and just
your your body of work it would be
you know i'm surprised to hear you
question that but i think that's a
healthy questioning though just being
realistic
yeah yeah i mean i think i think that's
part is not taking it for granted and
not never assuming
that the future is going to be what the
present is because it probably won't be
and you know i've shot
i've only ever shot one
project that anyone has heard of and
and that so
i think i've shot 10
[Music]
seasons of tv
and one
got you know it
was a hit to some capacity at least for
its size nobody's ever heard of the
features i shot like it's
you never know
what's gonna go in what direction and so
for me
uh it's really important that i love the
work the craft which i do
because you have no control over the
other elements of it and so
i try to when i when i can pay attention
to who am i working with the people make
a real difference just in terms of
quality of life day to day
but
yeah i mean
you never know what's gonna work or
what's not gonna work or what anybody
will find i've shot i shot
i don't remember now four or five series
for um go 90 which was a verizon
streaming service which doesn't exist
anymore uh so even even the full
streaming service the the channel just
ceased to exist let alone those shows
but
i loved the work and i'm proud of the
work we did on a lot of those shows i
really i hope they find themselves at
home because some of them are
really good shows
but again i have no control over that
and so learning to let go
helps is you just control what you can
which is on set on the day you do as
good a job as you can be pleasant to
work with enjoy it because that's you
know that's still your life
day to day there
so yeah
it's weird it's very it's very strange
it's it's depressing when i think about
the realities of the industry i tend to
get pretty discouraged you know i
because i would like to i would like to
put some roots down buy a house one day
or whatever that might look like and
i don't know when or if or
how that'll go so
yeah but for now i still love the work
like i get excited i just read a script
this week for a feature that may or may
not happen
and uh in the new year and it's like oh
yeah how would i shoot this shot and who
how what's the look of this i still get
really excited about that so i let i let
that lead me but you know i'm in my 40s
so you are okay i i did not know that i
thought you were much younger okay yeah
no no it's yeah it's the years
yeah it's sleeping well it's a pandemic
okay well i gotta give you that
i'm sure there's other folks out there
that
are in a similar boat they're looking
for work they're ready for work
but
it's not there or whatever the case may
be how do you keep yourself in check you
said you have a meditation practice
yeah i mean so i know
myself well enough at this point
and i'm still learning i've figured out
all my quirks but i know that if i don't
go for walks i will start to go crazy um
going to the movie theater has always
been a big thing for me i always feel
very um
at peace in a movie theater but that is
not an option these days so
trying to i've not gotten myself out to
nature often enough
but i know that that usually a few days
of camping will usually kind of reset me
uh
but how i eat and making sure there's
some exercise in my life
and i almost take it like medicine it
has nothing to do with
oh
today's a good day to exercise or i feel
like exercising no no no like i have to
because i will lose my mind otherwise
and so a part of it is really just
being able to have the discipline i
guess
which is for me feels strange to say
because i don't think of myself as a
disciplined person but
for
anything that
anything regarding filmmaking i've
always been able to convince myself
to do something for the greater good so
keeping myself healthy for my own life
maybe doesn't work but to keep myself
healthy
so that i'm a better filmmaker so that
hour 13 i'm still energetic
that's somehow always been able
been a way that i've been able to keep
myself
you know
happy and healthy to some degree and
i've always struggled with anxiety and
so i have these little things that i
just know i need to do or you know i
could lose a handle and who knows just
go crazy so
here's johnny here's johnny exactly no i
mean i mean i make light of it but i
think a lot of we're all there in
somewhere and because this is uncharted
territory
and and we thought we'd seen the worst
with the great recession and then
there's so many aspects that we're just
you know
this is you know
been a very trying year in so many ways
for sure yeah yeah and i will say i mean
gratitude
is a big that's something i'm really
trying to practice
is just being thankful for i mean the
fact that i shot a show that found an
audience and that people like
i'm so grateful for that after years of
just grinding and you know it felt like
i was banging my head against a wall and
then it's like oh people like this
that's great and it feels good but it's
also
like that's already gone and so just to
be grateful that something like that
grateful for my health you know
anything that you can be grateful for
i think goes a long way i think it's
easy
to to spiral
in a global pandemic in a country that
is
uh you know pretty divided and a lot of
anger and frustration
i think
i don't you know it's dangerous you
don't want to ignore
anything but is finding the things that
make you
bring you some sort of peace and even
joy i think is so important remember why
you know
why do you want to live this life like
why oh yeah right like hugging i
remember hugging hugging's pretty good
i'm assuming we'll do that again one day
so there's just yeah trying to be
grateful for as much as you can and you
know
when i moved into my new house i bought
myself a really nice tv and i was like
oh this is really expensive i don't know
if i should
but i did knowing that i had a show
coming and i was like okay i can
rationalize the cost but now in the
pandemic i love that i have this huge tv
and i'm watching you know all manner of
things and
it's a nice little treat and i can't go
to a movie theater but i have a nice
setup at home which i didn't have
forever so
you know i'm thankful for that
gratitude i think is a good a good tool
hard to exercise but yeah
what's your favorite thing to watch on
this new tv now
oh man you know what i've been really i
mean i'm all over the place but i
have i love watching a movie from like
the 70s or 80s where it has this like
beautiful film grain
and i love
watching the grain because my the tv is
really nice and the uh the blacks like
go really black so if you watch somebody
like gordon willis you know a legendary
cinematographer
his work he really leaned into
people called him the prince of darkness
and you watch these images that are
really dark but they have this grain
dancing through it film grain is such a
i have such a like a romantic
nostalgic reaction to it so it makes me
really happy to watch films with a ton
of grain dirt it's it's funny i have
this clean tv and my favorite things are
the the dirty images you'll love those
yeah
that's awesome
now i love sometimes watching 90s 80s
talk shows
i mean i love phil donahue jenny jones
there's just something
you can't i don't know there's something
very romantic about i know it sounds
yeah really but there is nostalgic this
like
you know phil donahue and the hairstyles
and totally yeah yeah nostalgia is a
superpower yeah
for anyone who wants to learn
cinematography what are some of the best
exercises they can do right now
well
if you're trying to learn cinematography
right now i mean
i would say take out your phone and just
shoot images and try to edit them
together i think that's a bit a big part
of shooting at least for narrative but i
would assume this is true of anything
but i i'm more narrative is my field
is the
the way a sequence comes together
is a big part of my job it's not just
pretty images um pretty images are great
they're really fun but
it's how
you know i mean you know as something as
basic as wide shot and a couple
close-ups but getting used to that
watching
you know if you're filming a person this
was a big thing i remember when i
started to learn this and
working with when i was inexperienced
and working with inexperienced directors
and an actor would finish their last
line and then they'd start walking
his directors would always have me
follow them
and then there was no place to cut
and i realized like oh but if you let
them exit frame and then you cut right
there it's cleaner as opposed to a
moving shot that then just cuts
and so
you know our phones are wonderful
cameras they're better than the cameras
i started with so like i i there's no
shame in shooting with a phone when
everybody's got one
so i think doing that but then yeah on
your phone they have editing programs or
whatever so whatever is
whatever you have at your fingertips use
that
but trying to
learn
how something comes together i mean i
i'm not super tick tock familiar but
i've seen some videos on there and i
have to say it's pretty incredible
watching some of the edits some of them
are unexpected it's quick it's there's a
rhythm to it and i guess maybe that's a
part of it too is the rhythm of how a
sequence comes together so i think
shooting
but more specifically shooting
and editing so that you see what doesn't
work because it's really making mistakes
that's how you're going to get better is
by screwing up
yeah how did you begin editing films
when you first got your camera
well let's see my first when i the first
editing i did was super eight so i guess
that was you know
film and it was you had this little box
where you cut it and so you're i mean
you're literally holding up images and
you're taping it together so i mean it's
like proper old school which really
makes
you think about what you're shooting now
with digital you know you can just shoot
shoot shoot and i think that can be i
mean it's wonderful but it can be
dangerous because you're not making as
many decisions ahead of time and i'm a
believer in at least
doing things thoughtfully and then
experiment off of that
uh but after that i mean i boy i think
i've edited every which way i've edited
on a flatbed edited film by hand i did
uh what i had like a
a sketch comedy show i did at my local
cable access
and that was editing vhs to vhs but you
had to edit it linearly so it wasn't
non-linear edit so it was
you'd pick your shot from here and then
on this other i i barely even remember
it i remember it being a big pain in the
butt though
and so i yeah i edited i think yeah
every single way that you can edit i
think i've tried and now i'm getting
further and further away from it because
i'm
you know shooting i have a few directors
well maybe not even a few maybe just a
couple
who involve me in the edit but usually i
shoot and then that's it i don't see it
again until it's time for color
um
but some directors
will send me rough cuts and ask for some
my thoughts and i love that because i
i consider that all part of my job the
rhythm of a sequence and how it feels
how it progresses
uh i'm i i love talking to editors uh
rather directors in terms of editing i
think talking to a director about
editing how a sequence will come
together tells you
a bit about the tone like starting wide
ending up close something as basic as
that but
the movement of a thing is the sequence
going to end static are we gonna do we
want the whole thing to
so so for me
editing is very connected to
cinematography uh which is dangerous
because often i'm kept out of that part
of it
so yeah
how has the rhythm changed over the
years i know you said earlier that you
were able to get a big screen tv and
you're you love watching the film grain
of old movies
but how is the rhythm from old movies to
now changed
yeah i think a lot about rhythm of
modern film versus versus older films
because you know audiences are we're
we're used to
montage we're used to i mean you you see
a 30-second commercial now
can have i mean i don't i don't even
know how to hazard a guess i mean it
could have 300 cuts in it you know like
it it
but audiences are savvy so they can take
that in the question is
you know what is helping
your message a bit more i have over the
last few years and this is the influence
i think of a specific director i worked
with charles hood
he is very aware of when edits come
and
he
he has really influenced how i think of
it is there there's some kind of a quote
it might be walter merch and i'm sure
i'm butchering it but every cut every
time you cut you're letting the audience
off the hook
so it's sort of this idea of as you know
a scene is even if it's just dialogue
just two people talking if you're able
to block it out in such a way or just a
you know walk and talk they're walking
and you're just the camera's leading
if you can let that shot linger
it seems to me
that you're more invested in the
in the scene and as soon as it starts
cutting and then it cuts and then it
cuts and it cuts
that it's it's being almost pieced
together later
and i do think there's something about
that
i don't know it almost reminds you that
you're watching a film or something
whereas when shots are longer and you
hold for longer which is hard to do
because that can get very boring
but if you can block a scene well and
you know the actors in conjunction with
the camera
and they sort of you can land in a
close-up and then this actor moves here
and they go and the camera moves you
it's it's a dance and if that's
choreographed well
i i think that's about the best that you
can do is fewer cuts and and a part of
it is also watching filmmakers who i
love like paul thomas anderson somebody
i love one of the great filmmakers
working
he does not cut a ton he he let he lets
the scenes breathe
but that's you know that's not for
everyone it's not to say it's right or
wrong but in terms of
keeping people in
in the story that's something that i
think helps i think that's a tool that
really helps people stay engaged is
fewer cuts now we'll see how i feel a
few years from now but currently that's
something that i'm trying to get better
at is choreography
what makes a beautiful shot what makes a
beautiful shot
well beautiful is a tricky word i think
um
yeah that's boy i don't even know how i
would begin to answer that because a
beautiful shot
well you know there is a basic thing to
to me
uh
backlit something that's backlit if the
light is behind coming through
uh
that that's always a good place to start
but
beauty is such a strange word because
there's
i think at least for my work working in
long-form narrative
i think
beauty is all relative to the story so
it's really what what keeps you
my translation i suppose of that
question would lean me toward like what
fits
a scene
like what what if the emotion of the
scene is loneliness
you know the word beauty is going to be
interpreted differently what's a
beautiful way to shoot loneliness or a
beautiful way of shooting madness
you know and then so is beauty actually
beauty or is it
uh
i think i think it's all just relevant
to the story and the intention of a
moment or a scene and so there are spots
where ugly is beauty you know which i
which i like i like i like that it's
malleable and it should be
uh because you know
any director is going to interpret the
same script
in their own way any cinematographer is
going to interpret it their own way
so beauty yeah beauty
it's interesting because i have a
director who maria marioli who
she has an aesthetic that i really like
and so shooting with her
is
pleasurable because it's almost
it's just
it's almost the cleanest definition of
beauty in a way like we've we've tended
anything that we've done together we've
just tried to make
beautiful in the most
simplistic terms you know like beautiful
people beautiful places beautiful
costumes beautiful light
and
it's really fun to do that i really love
doing that
but
she might be the only director who i
work with where i ca
the word beautiful
even fits everywhere else it just feels
so
relative to the moment like what's the
the intention
almost becomes more important than
beautiful so i feel like that's not much
of an answer but it's so hard the word
beauty
for my jaw i actually you know what i'll
add to this
i was um
[Music]
on facebook i have a few cinematography
groups that i was part of and i
noticed every time i would get off i
would be on there for a little bit and
every time i'd get off i'd feel really
bad about myself
and it was because people were posting
beautiful stills from commercials music
videos whatever it was and i'd look at
their stills and i'd just be like i've
never shot a still that looks like that
that looks beautiful like that
and it really was getting to me
and then
i was working on a show and i was
thinking about it as i was on set and i
was like well this shot could we
it's not beautiful and i was like wait
wait no no this isn't supposed to be
beautiful like the the last show i shot
pen 15
that was one of the mantras is like no
beauty
it is not a place for beauty and that's
you know we had a new gaffer come in for
season two and he'd light a close-up and
we'd be working on it and he'd bring in
a little fill light or whatever an
highlight or rim light whatever and i'm
like no no no you we got to get rid of
that that's too beautiful like if shots
were beautiful on that show
we would axe them we would we would try
and ugly it up a little bit
so
yeah so on that show beauty was the
enemy in a way which is
tricky that's interesting i watched both
trailers season one season two and it
looks hilarious i'd love to watch the
the full uh show
is that because it's supposed to show
the awkwardness of like junior high or
what
i'm not sure exactly how old they are
but yeah yeah they're they're junior
high and yeah it's it's a show about
awkwardness
and
and it's supposed to play real you know
it's it's a weird setup there are 30
year olds playing 13 year olds with
other actual 13 year olds
but we wanted to play it
naturalistic and so
you don't want like you don't want
close-ups to look beautiful you don't
want i mean
there was nothing about puberty that
felt beautiful to me
and so
that was a big part of it and so we we
uglied up the image a lot we added noise
we shot with noise in camera and then we
added grain and we would make sure it
wasn't too saturated and it was it was a
real dance but that was the the mantra
is and that came from from the creators
they were like we don't want a beautiful
show we want this to there was a show a
movie that we used as reference welcome
to the dollhouse which is yeah and it's
a great like 90s indie movie
and that's what they kept saying is like
how would we shoot this as a 90s indie
movie where we don't have resources what
you know
how would we approach this and making
sure to not make something beautiful
because often
i think that's what a lot of
cinematographers
think their job is is to make beautiful
images and i don't think that's the job
i think i think you're there to create
help create a story and help hold up a
story in that the the atmosphere that
you're creating the visuals you're
creating now that doesn't mean beauty
doesn't belong there
but it's it's in conjunction with the
story where are the relationships where
are the characters where's the arc right
now
and
leaning into beautiful shots that would
be great on a reel
i think is a very dangerous way to work
is that because you're always kind of
competing with yourself and you're
taking yourself out of the
trueness of the story
in terms of how do you mean well you
know because i was thinking like cinema
verite you know you're going to just
you're not you just want to show exactly
what's there right but so much of it now
is is trying to top not only your work
but other people's work whether it's on
instagram or whatever right yeah no
that's interesting because there is yeah
there is i mean there is something and i
do think about this is how to make
something stand out in a in a world full
of images
and
who are you comparing yourself against i
think i had i had i almost feel like a
an aesthetic breakthrough watching the
show atlanta
i because i was working in all these
half hours which i never thought that's
where i'd end up but i've been chewing
all these half hour shows
and i was struggling i was like how can
you like
i want to make something that's
cinematic that still feels like i'm
shooting a feature and how do you work
that in but
i think
you know then seeing a show like atlanta
and there was another show at the time
um i loved dick it was on amazon
and
very different shows but both of them
have a rawness to them and atlanta the
way that they shoot that is amazing
they're they're basically trying to
break the sensor of the alexa they're
under exposing by several stops and then
pulling it up so that they're pulling
out the noise which is the opposite of
how you're taught and the opposite of
how mo most people are shooting for
clean and i want everything kind there's
a perfect eye light and a rim light and
then atlanta came along
and it's so it looks like somebody you
know buried it underground for a month
and then dug it up and dusted off and
like here's your show and i loved it
because it has a personality it fits
with the the show like the story line
the characters they're broke and they're
struggling and
i
for me it really i felt like
it almost it was like i took training
wheels off of my bike because
i was shooting these shows for people
and they're they're for other people
you know show runner or a production
company or whatever directors
and so i was like well i don't i was
like very careful what about noise
people have a weird reaction to noise so
you have to shoot clean make sure
there's enough light and then i was like
well wait now i want
if they can do this and this is my
favorite show i've seen in years
then what can i do for my shows that
helps them and you know then i started
to look at a lot older lenses and i
started to really push myself a little
bit more uh in terms of not attaching to
beauty like don't don't let beauty be
the leader i think that became a big
part of my mantra not to say i won't
shoot beauty but there needs to be a
reason for it to be beautiful
and i find it interesting that you're
not interested in documentary or it's
not that you don't like it but that
you're more drawn to narrative
yeah you know i i love documentaries um
i
but part of what i am drawn to with
filmmaking is the creation of atmosphere
and i think in documentaries you can
absolutely do that but
i'm not as good at it so i uh i have a
friend who is a great documentary
filmmaker and i like watching him
because it it opens my eyes up to the
possibilities because now documentaries
are becoming so cinematic
and that to me is very exciting you know
that people the way people shoot
interviews now is so much more daring
than how it was just 10 years ago
and so
for doc because i do like the dirtiness
of life and the dirtiness of images i do
think i've got some good docs in me to
shoot
but yeah as of now it just hasn't hasn't
come my way but i would love to
okay
what are the basics of getting a great
shot with any camera from an iphone to
dslr
yeah i mean
i i suppose it's a little bit like your
previous question about a beautiful shot
like what makes a great shot because
it's so
it's so reliant on context
so
you know any type of any shot is where
is this going to fit into the montage of
images you know so so its place
is really more of what i think about
but you know on a technical level
there are certain things that i
will always be careful of you know
seeing
uh
usually you want to see unless there's a
reason you don't but
seeing an actor's eyes is important or
at least one eye because we we i think
as humans we connect to eyes even if you
take googly eyes and you put them on you
know a fork
suddenly you can bond with that fork
like it suddenly has human
characteristics so i think eyes are a
big thing to i don't think about that
consciously but i know when i'm looking
at a shot i'm shooting
figuring out where the eyes are and can
you see them and are there other things
in a frame that are drawing your eye
as opposed to an actor's face you know
that's a big part of it
so
i think
maybe the way i'd put it is
i want to know in a shot
where do i want the audience to look and
how do i want them to feel when they
look there
and so if you have a big wide shot and
there's an actor somewhere
but there are other elements in the
frame like a big
turquoise
teddy bear or a big shiny something or
other
i want to make sure and maybe that helps
the scene and maybe that helps the shot
but
i need to know what a shot is intended
to do the ideal is
and then i can work from there
and
often
you end up with a frame you start with a
frame rather
where there's too much pulling the eye
and i know this shot you need to go to
that actor right away so that means we
need to knock down this wall this wall
is too bright so let's make sure and
knock this light down so it's not
hitting that wall
this you know these sometimes there's
something like an element of costume
that like oh in this shot these red
boots are too much maybe we frame them
out maybe we but it becomes like i guess
that's really
what it is for me is it becomes about
what's the intention and where do you
want people to look and then you just
start almost chiseling you you're you're
like it's a sculpture and you're trying
to get rid of the pieces that don't need
to be there so that people are drawn
to the piece be that through composition
or lighting or color or
size and frame
but i think that would be how i would
approach it and then you know
in terms of different cameras have
different latitudes
so like a an alexa
has you know 15-ish stops of latitude so
you can have your dark to your light but
an iphone is significantly less
and if something if there's a white spot
that is blown out
is just no information and it that can
it can be
ugly
and it can pull your eye because it's so
bright and bare so there are
technical limitations to different
sensors
and
that also can be a part of it is just
something that's that's less
artistically driven and more technical
and you're like well this this camera
the sensor is going to break unless we
knock down this light and shoot it all
within a better latitude but again the
intention is the same it's because you
don't want them looking at the wrong
thing and
and having their mind
you know drift to something else you
you're sort of trying to be intentional
about everything within a frame
what is lighting and why do we light
lighting yeah it's funny when i started
lighting
in grad school
it was
purely motivated by exposure i was
shooting on film i started shooting on
reversal 16 which is you know
difficult to light and does not have
much latitude and if you screw up it's
gone
and so i was lighting purely
to have exposure so if you looked at
some of the films that student films
that i had lit
there was nothing attractive about them
but they were exposed
uh but now
you know i suppose it goes back to like
your question about a great shot or
something it's it's
intention it's always intention so it's
trying to
enhance whatever mood you're looking for
uh is be that something is you know
beautiful or scary or and you know there
is also um
i don't know where this where or when
this started but when i'm on set very
often there will be and i don't know
what it is and this is tricky uh
is i'll be looking at an image on
monitor and we'll be lighting it
and it won't
feel like anything that's what i'll say
like this isn't something like this
isn't i don't what does it need and and
sometimes i don't know and so i'll go
back to okay
when i when i'm feeling lost like a shot
isn't working i'll go back to what is
the scene where is this character right
now and
okay if this is the emotion what does
that mean to me in terms of lighting and
then you know i interpret it however i
interpret or i talk to my gaffer or
director or key grip and
and i'll kind of
talk it out and feel it out and
sometimes it takes some experimenting
but there is this thing it's not the
best way to work but it's how i've
worked for years now
where
we'll start futzing if i'm if i'm
feeling like this shot isn't doing what
i wanted to do the light isn't doing
what i wanted to do like well what if we
turn that off and and we'll well what if
okay maybe take away the diffusion there
and then
something will happen
and i'm like oh this is something like i
don't like now it feels like something
it like has personality to it and it's
such a it's really difficult to explain
because the truth is i often don't know
why
i i can't you know i do all my prep work
so i try to
marinate in in the show's intention it
shows mood a show's atmosphere
but then you know when you're shooting
shot after shot and you're on the the
1000th shot of a show that you're
shooting
and you're trying to find something and
it's not there
i really and i part of it feels like a
little bit of magic i don't know what
that is
but
the light i'm ver i'm always very
conscious of light
and sometimes it just doesn't feel right
and i don't even know what that means
like what is right what if there's no
such thing as right or wrong
but something
in me
is not responding to what we're doing
and
very often it's uh it's because of the
light
and so it's it's not much of a specific
answer but
that is
something and the leader is the
intention the intention of the scene the
intention of like just
just trying to think of where your
characters are
and
sometimes a light can be too dominant or
sometimes it's not enough or sometimes
it's drawing the eye to the wrong place
uh because it can you know
just like a door frame and
a shaft of light like these are all ways
to direct the eye
and so i think
for light it's it's just another tool
another way to direct the eye and direct
intention or mood i guess
so a bit of a babbling answer but
it's kind of how i feel about it
sometimes it just is this mishmash of
concepts that you're trying to hone in
and then
something clicks you're like yeah that's
what it is
it's weird and referring back to pen 15
your hulu project the two two one two
um
you said with that one it was not to
make scenes pretty right so with the
lighting again you were not using any
kind of fillers or
yeah it was so
yeah
we approached so you know i mean so the
show's naturalistic uh in general and so
i mean some of the basics are if we're
in a bedroom
the light is going to if it's bedroom
daytime and that's a big part of it i
work with the script supervisor very
closely for a number of reasons but one
of them is i like to track time of day
it doesn't mean i'm going to always
stick to it but you know
i always am checking with her i'm like
okay so this scene is this like
you know two o'clock and she's like
actually no it's like five o'clock and
so some i'm like oh okay so then we'll
we'll lower the sun that's coming in a
window so it'll and we let
how it might actually be lead the scene
that that'll at least be
if you think of it as like a hunk of
clay that you're shaping
you
just getting the hunk
is like where to even start and that's
often what it is it's like okay it's 5
p.m we're about to go to dinner with
these kids so it should not so it should
be a little darker let's start and so
part of it is smoothing out transitions
because you know the next scene is just
night and so it's like okay well you
don't want to jump from noon to night
unless you want to jump from noon to
night and so you let
the
the way it would actually be you let
that be the leader so a lower sun coming
in the side and then you decide with
with everybody you know the art crew and
the directors like okay these blinds
open closed it's gonna change the look
in the room and you can intention should
always be the leader but sometimes
you're just you're like okay i don't
this is too bright okay well then maybe
we throw a tree branch in front of it
try and break it up we
diffusion or maybe it's a cloudy day you
want it to feel like a cloudy day or
feel like a sunny day and these are all
decisions i mean it's it that's really
what a lot of it is it's just a ton of
small decisions
that hopefully are being led by a
concept
and then eventually you find yourself in
a place that feels right and i think
that helps i think when you lead with
intention and you know what the
character's state of mind is at a
particular time
it really helps because you can make
tons of decisions are the lights on in
the room are they off is the overhead on
or is the lamp on are the blinds open or
the blind's closed is it cloudy is it
sunny is it rainy is is the sun over
here because you decide you know was or
should we put the sun there
it you can get overwhelmed by options
but if you have places to start if you
know the story if you know the
characters
that at least gives you can at least
point your ship in a direction and i
think that for me at least uh is huge
that's everything otherwise i'd go
insane because you can light any scene a
million different ways
there were a lot of scenes where the the
two protagonists were in front of their
lockers
and sort of like the horrific halls
of the junior high
and and sort of the the the bareness and
ugliness of of you know you're on
display for everyone yeah yeah no and
that's and we debated uh especially in
season one when we were shooting locker
scenes by the locker in the ugly hallway
you're like well you know the light
people tend to look better if the light
is coming from the non-camera side just
in terms of if you're just you know no
intention or anything it's just nice if
it's
coming from the opposite side people
it'll be flatter if it's coming from the
camera
and
so we'd start to lean into that but then
we're like well
but
they're in the school hallway where they
feel exposed and they feel like
uncomfortable so maybe that's actually
good is that you do it what might be the
wrong way you know and and and you're
juggling those decisions and sometimes
your intention is one thing and then you
look at it and you're like well it just
doesn't work and then you try it another
way and for whatever reason it works and
you respond to it
uh but i think that's also part of it is
being in being in tune with everything
and seeing what you respond to because
it's just so
arbitrary in a way the way that i'm
going to respond to something doesn't
mean everyone will
but you hope that if if your intentions
are dialed in
and that's what's leading your decisions
that's kind of the sum of all of those
parts leads to it feeling the way you
want it to feel i guess
what is color temperature and why is it
important
yeah color temperature is a is an
interesting one
i
so
in terms of just its beginnings um
traditionally now it's changing because
of leds but traditionally
uh
homes are lit with tungsten which is a
around 3200 it's a warmer color
temperature and daylight is 5600 6000
sunlight uh color temperature which is
bluer and so that's kind of
the general starting point i would say
for color temperature 3200 is tungsten
which
traditionally is home
interior
and
uh 56 is 5600 is sunlight and outdoors
which is bluer
and then from there
there's everything and so
you know i was fond for a while uh of
shooting scenes
uh that that were like if we were inside
in the daytime
and there were a couple lamps on i would
shoot i shot uh i think two whole series
the whole thing basically the whole
thing at 4 400
uh camera setting
and so that meant every lamp was a
little warm and all daylight was a
little cool
and i really there's something about
that that i really like
but now
the last couple years for whatever
reason the projects i'm on or if it's my
own personal aesthetic i don't really
know
i've gotten
more conscious of trying to match and
choose any pops of color very carefully
so
if you're shooting inside
and it's well
evening so evening can be a tricky time
to try and light because it's like oh
you know in your life
there's a point where you're in your
house where you turn on the lights like
where it's getting a little too dark but
there's still light coming in
and so
figuring out if you're in a scene again
intention is the leaders do you want it
to feel
very cozy in the house
and maybe you're gonna shoot
right if you shoot right at 3200 then
everything in the house will feel
quote unquote normal
but then that little blue light coming
in will feel a little extra blue
or
you can say oh this is that transition
and it was just afternoon and now we're
starting to feel
uh
like the evening is coming on
and there's still that twinge of
daylight outside so we're gonna stay at
5000 in camera let's say and then you
turn on the lights in the house and it's
very warm and then that feels new or
different
so
there are ways to play it that give just
this edge of some kind of emotion one
way or another like
and so that
i think that's the easiest way to talk
about
how to start with it but you can also
make all of your lights all one color
temperature
and then everything is just even but
color contrast is something that more
and more i'm becoming very conscious of
is
if you want something to feel
very blue
then sometimes it helps to have
something orange because you need that
contrast
which is very interesting because if you
start watching scenes that are just blue
blue blue every over and over and over
your eyes our eyes are pretty incredible
and they will adjust very quickly
and so that blue the same exact blue if
you watch it for five minutes by the
time you're at that fifth minute
is gonna feel white because we adjust
very quickly but if you hold color
contrast somewhere a little orange or
whatever that is you keep the eyes
anchored in a way and so that because
that's something that i i really i've
always been conscious of but i worked
with a colorist who uh season one of
penn 15.
he brought an element of color contrast
that i think really helps that first
season season two is kind of a different
look but season one
he was he started adding a little bit of
blue to our shadows
and to kind of contrast with skin tones
and some of the production design and i
loved it but it's nothing i intended
going in and that ended up coming in
during our first week of shooting he was
there helping us create luts
so
you know
color temperature
is
one of the big tools for sure i mean
color of any kind and color temperature
is where it begins because every and
especially now
uh using leds
you can dial in
literally millions of colors and so you
know
what do you do with that that's a lot of
power and a lot more uh decision making
so it's yeah it's a it's a it's a dance
and it's a tricky dance
for sure you can go
too far or you can go not far enough so
yeah
well if you go too far does that make it
look too
you know artsy and then it takes you out
of you know especially when you talked
about in the height the halls of the
junior high it's he wanted to be more
stark and like oh wow everybody's on
display here right good and bad yeah
well so again it goes back to what's the
intention of the
project you know because there are
there are shows i would love to shoot a
show with a ton of color i did a show
that was kind of a mockumentary years
ago it was about these djs and so
because it was djs these really rich
guys with not great taste
and they're live in this big dj world we
were using color all over the place and
it was a blast it was really fun
uh but
that we did that because it enhanced the
the the feeling in the world whereas pen
there wasn't the color really is in the
um
costumes
the costumes are very colorful in pen 15
and the bedrooms of the of the girls are
a ton of color in there and so for me it
became about
letting the lights be a little more
natural and just using colors to dictate
time of day mood or enhance or bring
back skin tones that kind of thing
but yeah the color of those shows
because they are colorful shows but my
end is not colorful at all we were
draining color out very often
so it's it's a because that's another
part of it is production design costumes
the actors themselves like what are
their skin tones these are all
pieces of the puzzle and you're trying
to make it all kind of fit and not be
you know make it consistent and no no
one element overwhelming another like
it's it's like a soup you know if you
put too much ginger in a soup then
suddenly it overwhelms everything else
so
yeah
zoom versus primes which are better
yeah there's
so zoom lenses and prime lenses they
both have pros and cons uh for sure and
um it's a big
it's a big subject um
traditionally zoom lenses are slower so
uh
meaning you can't let as much light in
or they need you to have more light
whereas prime lenses this is not a rule
it's just traditionally it's how it lays
out so prime lenses tend to be faster
so you know in terms of a t-stop or an
f-stop
you can open up more
and let it have a shallower depth of
field let more light in
but you a prime lens you know is like a
25 millimeter and that's all it is 25 is
a 25
whereas a zoom
let's say because there's also a huge
range of zooms you can have a 25 to 78
or you can have a 25 to 250
and when these lens you know and some of
these zooms are huge
so
there's a l there's a lot of decision
making that goes into what lenses you're
using
and the prime versus zoom is one of the
big ones
there's also speed so if you're shooting
on
let's say a reality tv show you pretty
much have to have a zoom lens because
you need to be able to
go in and it doesn't mean you're zooming
in during a shot though it could but it
also just to reset is you know you have
a wide shot and then you adjust your
body however you can but you don't want
to be in the way so if you want to get a
close-up on a reality show
you just zoom in from where you are
uh that's kind of like the the very
broad strokes
but there's a lot you know the
like a dolly move
versus a zoom in
they have a different feel to them and
what's happening to the background is
very different and where your character
or your subject in space the way
a zoom as you zoom in it tends to it
flattens the image whereas if you're on
a prime if you're on a 35 millimeter and
you're moving in everything is still
staying you're able to isolate
characters more so there are a lot of
qualities
that they're so difficult to see and
feel and i'm very lucky because
last five years i've been shooting so
much
so now i am at a place where a 20 what a
24 millimeter does to a
you know let's say a medium close-up
shooting that if you
shoot this on a 24 millimeter from right
here
and then you move it back
just
six inches and you put on a 28
millimeter
i for me there's a big difference
between the two but it's taken
just hours you know so many hours on set
and and looking through different lenses
and watching their effect
is what it does to the image some of it
you can explain like if i'm moving my
hands and i'm on a 25 millimeter it's
going to be exaggerated my face will be
a little rounder
what does that mean it makes me feel
maybe a little more silly or a little
more cartoonish but if you move back and
even though this the the top and bottom
of the frame are exactly the same on a
50 millimeter
none of those things are exaggerated
anymore it's almost a little like a 50
would be
normal
and so
that becomes a tool
and so then within that you're deciding
like a prime versus a zoom what is worth
what are your trade-offs because on a
zoom you can reset really quickly
but primes tend to have more character
to them or be cleaner or you know so
that it's it's all pros and cons and and
it's you know it's just like
if you're if you're grabbing grabbing
paints if you're painting your house you
know and they have those swatches
there's like yellow but really it's like
this is goldilocks this one's dandelion
this and they have such subtle
differences but there are differences
and that's what lenses kind of bring
they all have different characteristics
and
zoom and prime are the two big
categories but then even within that
there are a number of different things
that will differentiate one from another
and and you know time money resources
are part of that decision it's not all
purely aesthetic
a lot of it is like well we won't have
time to change primes or
whatever like we need to be able to
hustle hustle hustle um
yeah so it's yeah there's there's a lot
there's a lot in there
what's a what's a good starting lens
aside from like sort of the stock camera
lens that's going to come with the body
what would you recommend if somebody
wants to upgrade just a little bit yeah
i mean
well
so i think you know choosing a lens if
you're starting
if you could only start with one lens
one size and this is assuming because
different cameras have different size
sensors
so a 35 millimeter lens
does
the lens is always the lens but if your
sensor like our phones have a very small
sensor
so
a 35 millimeter on the well that's maybe
a bad way to start that
a 35 millimeter is always the lens is
the lens
but if you have a large sensor then a 35
millimeter plays very wide and if you
have a smaller sensor
then a 35 millimeter plays a little
tighter
so your camera but the sort of standard
size is
super 35 is the first sensor so that's
what most things are
and
i would say assuming you have one of the
more common
cameras
that i would choose between a 35 or a 50
as the i would lean 35 but i know most
people would lean 50.
um
and i think that's because they're
close-ish to
our vision or at least that's how people
say because really in reality if you pay
attention i'm looking at you but i'm i
can see my peripheral vision is pretty
wide
so you could argue oh that's a 25
millimeter but my attention is really on
you
and you could argue that that means that
i'm not really watching the outskirts
and so really that's a 50 millimeter
and so it's it's you know it depends now
for me a 35 millimeter
is a really nice size because you can
shoot a wide and you can shoot a
close-up
but if you get in close on a 35
it does have a little roundness to it
so
it's yeah maybe maybe the answer is a 42
which is a hard lens size to find but
yeah i think those those are the
normal hero sizes i would say is a 35
and a 50 i think would be the two
sizes
that
one would start with i think
what's the best way to take care of the
lenses so they're not scratched
different elements yeah working with
sand for sure yeah lenses require a lot
i mean you need to treat lenses like a
like a baby like they are they are even
though a lot of them are built very
rugged the glass is glass
and so you know i'm very lucky i have a
great camera team
and so i rarely touch a lens you know my
first ac second ac
they bring it on they take everything
out they're they're
you know
they take everything out with care
they've they're also professionals
they've been doing it for years so
but you do need to treat a lens you need
to be constantly looking at when you
take it off and you put it on you need
to check both sides up against the light
because dust particles get in there and
if a dust particle is in the wrong part
of frame
it will affect your image sometimes
dramatically
so you really need to take care of them
um
some people will have a uh a uv filter
which is basically just
clear glass it does it functionally it
does serve a bit of a purpose but really
uh i did that for a long time i've
gotten a little away from it now uh but
i have a set of rokinons which are cheap
lenses
uh but i think the best bang for the
buck they don't have a ton of
personality but they are really good for
their price like a rokinon lens and you
can get ones that have
gears on them so if you're using a
follow focus
and those are like
i think for a and they're really fast
really fast uh i think they're like 200
bucks for a lens and for a good lens
with gears on it that's really fast
uh i think that's the the best lens you
can get in terms of somebody beginning
uh and i would just choose one of those
if you can uh and
yeah i think that's
i think that's where i'd start i still
have mine and they used to have those
filters on top in terms of protecting
them but now that i'm more comfortable
and i'm like i'm probably not going to
screw this thing up
i i don't have live on there but you
know if you're shooting out in the woods
or shooting at the beach or in the
desert is a
nightmare for lenses and for camera
sensors it just gets in gears it gets in
the fan and you you everything needs to
be protected and sometimes that's
putting plastic or fabric around it and
yeah film equipment strong as it is you
still need to treat it very gently
how long did it take you to fully grasp
all the camera settings
i
you know there are a lot of cameras that
i couldn't run but actually most cameras
i couldn't run by myself at this point i
don't i am uh
i am
i'm very reliant on my
camera team for sure uh i am always
familiar with how different camera
sensors react to light and color skin
tones
the noise floors like i i pay attention
to the sensor and the reactivity uh but
often
i am not familiar with building out a
full camera with its wireless follow i
could i couldn't put together a wireless
follow focus and my camera team i'm so
rely i'm reliant on them for a number of
things
but for sure they like my first ac
bryant i've been working with him for
years i'm reliant on him for putting
together our camera even when we're
ordering equipment
i do broad strokes i'm like i want these
lenses these filters
i prefer this monitor
but in terms of the
cables and all the little the follow
focus
are wireless like i
i have some
leanings but really i leave that to him
and it becomes it's a big your camera
team ends up becoming a huge part of
your whole process and i'm for sure that
way and letting go of some of the
technical
uh elements was tricky for me because i
felt like well wait a minute i'm the
cinematographer i'm supposed to know
everything and i was like oh no no no i
need to know how the image will end up
how we get there and the gear that's on
the camera
if some of it matters to me because i
have you know if i know it's handheld
i'm going to have different needs as
opposed to if i know i'm going to be on
dolly and all that but
yeah in terms of the
you know the settings or switching
things over to you know i mean now the
alexa mini i've been shooting with that
camera predominantly for the last few
years i'm very familiar with that
just because of the number of times but
you know if i were shooting on let's say
a sony venice or or a red it's been a
while since i've shot on a red
i would probably need help changing the
color temperature or the iso or frame
rate or all that and i i have no problem
asking for help with that stuff i don't
i don't feel like that's part of my job
description i need to understand it i
need to understand where what i'm
looking to get out of it but getting
there i'm content to let my acs help
guide me
what technical part of the craft took
you the longest to learn yeah the
technical the
cinematography really is technical and
actually i there's a feature
that i may be shooting you know who
knows now but uh that we might shoot on
film
and i am excited but also very nervous
about it because i have i was trained up
on film
but
to
light
boldly or dramatically for film is much
scarier than for digital because
with all our cameras now we have a
monitor and you can see what the image
is going to look like right now on film
you can't do that you have your light
meter out and you're talking about like
contrast ratios and how much light is
here versus here and where you can
you know i'm now used to i light off of
my monitor i almost never i bring a
light meter to set i almost never touch
it i'm really using the monitor and
to go back to film
scares me a little bit because i want to
make sure i can still be bold with my
choices
but i have to make sure that it's not
too contrasty or too
you know too flat like i don't it it's
really so i think
it's funny
in a way
the thing that now intimidates me or
makes me nervous on the technical side
is the thing that i learned first and
we've just because of technology have
gotten away from that
and now to go back to it and like oh i
don't have the safety of knowing what my
image is going to look like
right away you're kind of you have to go
back to
your own faith and understanding the
latitude of a film stock and contrast
ratios how it reacts to color
so i think that's the thing that right
now probably makes me the most nervous
on a on a technical level but
you know there are
i think there's also you know there's
there's all kinds of things like how to
bit rates and
you know
uh uh like a lot of our dslrs
for their color it's like 4-2-2
and i'm used to shooting 4-4-4 on an
alexa mini and for a long time i had no
concept of what that is and now i
understand oh
this is like the the way it captures
color and why that's important to me is
because it allows for gradation between
like
different like blues in a sky like it
starts usually by the horizon it's a
little gray gets a little bluer and then
deeper blue as you go up and different
camera sensors can't handle that because
of the way they capture color
so
i didn't
it that isn't something that i ever
learned because i was interested in the
technical but i was interested in like
well why why am i not getting the
smoothness of a color transition
so
that stuff has come to me kind of just
by
shooting it's not like i sat and was
studying books and
got it that way it's just kind of
learning because of really broken images
and how do i not break this image next
time that kind of thing
were you one of these kids that used to
take things apart to see how they worked
uh you know i i was always curious so i
would take things apart but not to see
how they worked i would take things
apart because i was just like i wonder
what the inside of this looks like
sounds like a serial killer
but yeah no i i actually
i would not call myself a technical
cinematographer now i that might not be
true i may actually be and i realize
sometimes like oh i know more stuff than
i thought
but i never
the leader of it is always like how does
this image feel like i look at when new
cameras get announced i will look at the
specs
but what i've learned is that like
listing the specs on paper kind of don't
matter to me now they give me a baseline
they help me understand frame rates how
will it do in low light what is its
native iso like there are technical
things that i now am very familiar with
and i understand what that means but
really i need to look at footage because
the way that they capture motion the way
that they capture skin tones the way
that they like the highlights the way
they blow out
like those are so my my
technical the technical information of
cameras has always been secondary to
my aesthetic reaction to it my emotional
reaction to the image for sure
yeah i think you probably do know a lot
more than you think but that maybe goes
along with the humility so well i also
think it's just years of doing it like
some of it just has has come because
i've i haven't understood why something
is a certain way and so it's out of
necessity but
yeah i would say out of necessity like
i'm just like what is it what is this
and so i've
but i've really i've been in it for so
long
so it's yeah i think that knowledge has
just
come almost through osmosis just through
wading through it for so long
do you prefer more setups and shots or
less setups and shots for a project
yeah i would
the fewer setups
generally the happier i am um
that's not to say that's always the
right way but i do notice there's
there's you know if i'm um
if we're hosing down a scene
uh meaning
okay we need to wide and then maybe we
get a second wide from here then we need
this medium and then let's go in for the
close-up but then also
i don't enjoy that um i feel like you're
just chasing and you're basically
gathering
um
pieces so that they can make it in an
edit so that in the edit so really and
this happens with a lot of projects
they're basically creating it in the
editing room
and nothing wrong with that but for me
personally
that doesn't interest me that much i
want to feel like we're making conscious
decisions uh on set
and
also the fewer
the this is what i tell directors a lot
too is the fewer the number of shots the
higher the quality so the more shots
you're shooting
the lower the quality each shot will be
just out of necessity you know like you
you can't make it and so
for me
trying to be uh intentional about why
you're shooting don't just shoot a
close-up because you need a close-up in
every scene like maybe we saved this
then it's more powerful when you use a
close-up in the next scene is being
intentional about how it goes is very
important to me because otherwise i
don't feel like i'm doing anything i
feel like
anybody could do it and that's fine i'm
not super interested in that
so yeah so for me the fewer the setups
oh man i'd love to shoot just like
a couple shots a day i might get bored
if that were actually the case but
that implies to me that we're really
structuring something and you're moving
the camera moves when it needs to move
and it will become and over the shoulder
you know like that that these things
progress and grow
uh and a shot can be multiple things in
one set up that's that's something i
really love it's hard but uh i think it
really plays beautifully in the end if
you approach it that way
you use intentional is that was that
from the four agreements
do you know that oh that is i i read
that i read that when i was going
through a bad breakup some years ago
yeah yeah yeah is that be intentional
with your word i think or something is
that one of them why um is it don louise
miguel or forget forgive me for the
author's name but i thought that that
was part of the the book but i could be
wrong that it was about the power of
intention and the intention of our
thoughts yeah it might be yeah yeah
yeah i find i find that that's
i mean it's a big part of i think how i
approach
my work is just what is this about and
let that drive because you can shoot any
scene anyway
and so
but that's not the point like the the
point is
this is
you know a film about loneliness or this
is a film about family and so okay well
what does that mean family is warmth
okay so that means maybe when the
family's together that means maybe that
the dinner table is warmer literally the
color temperature is warmer and it feels
cozy but then when they're out in the
world it's cooler and lonely or handheld
or you know it can very quickly
lead your decisions and that's how i
like to work i think that there's there
should be reason behind your decisions
do you put a metaphysical element to a
lot of
i try yeah i try yeah for sure i've got
a lot of hippie in me and so i love you
know
because it's still ultimately you're
looking for emotional reactions to
things you want to create emotional
reactions from the audience
and so i think like letting letting the
whole thing be ethereal if it needs to
be like i
i often the way when i'm starting a new
project
often i don't know what it wants to look
like or feel like and i'll just start
going through
images images and films and music and
just gather and you know with the
director or an actor whoever else are
the creatives involved is i just like to
gather and and going back to the soup
metaphor it's just like well okay you
don't like carrots all right so let's
not put any carrots in this soup and
it's like okay well do you like a spicy
soup oh okay so let's start adding and
and slowly
it really it doesn't feel like i'm
making decisions it really does often
feel like the
project is slowly revealing itself to me
when it's working really well
it does feel like there's a magic to it
and that the the project almost already
exists somewhere or like it's a little
creature somewhere and it's just slowly
you're like oh i think this creature is
furry i think it's got a blue tint to it
and it just like it starts to make sense
visually which is it's a weird way to
think about it but i find so pleasurable
because it feels like i'm hunting for
something and then slowly you start to
see glimpses of it and i love that
do you like things to be a challenge
in a sense
yeah i well it's interesting i
if i'm not
maybe instead of challenged it's
if i'm not engaged
in some way like i'm i'm feeling like
i'm adding something to it and i'm
working towards something i can get
bored for sure i i
i'm not
i'm not attracted to things that are
just like oh you know it's fine it's
whatever you just kind of put a light on
this side and we'll shoot it and we'll
figure it out like i
i get bored i definitely get bored so i
maybe i do need to get challenged i at
least need to be engaged i need to find
something to hook me in there have been
there have been projects that have come
my way that i was like this is just not
a good
fit i'm not this isn't something i'm
interested enough in i want to make sure
i'm
interested because it's just so much
time this is your life you know you're
gonna spend half a year
uh working on this thing so half a year
of your life like
it'd be nice if you care in some way one
way or another yeah
what's it like to shoot an average seven
to ten pages a day
yeah so shooting
shooting seven to ten pages a day is is
how a lot of tv goes that's one of the
things i'll look at often
[Music]
is
sometimes when i'm being interviewed for
a job
uh or close to being hired sometimes by
then they have uh
a page count and a number of shooting
days and one of the first questions i
will ask is like how many how many pages
a day are we shooting because it will
tell me
some element about how hard this job is
going to be
uh
i shot a show that we were averaging i
think we were averaging over 10 pages a
day
and it sucks it's you're just like
okay like just put up one light
somewhere and you're just going and
number of characters that's actually
secretly
that almost dictates more than because
i've noticed
uh yeah number of shooting days versus
number of pages versus number of
characters because if there is one
person
that you're shooting
there are only so many
shots of one person you need to do
but if there are eight people in a room
and it's even just a two-page scene but
everybody needs their own coverage i
shot i i shot a show
i shot two seasons of a show
that has
i don't know maybe 12 or 13 main
characters and sometimes they all get
together for dinner
and it is a nightmare of 180 lines and
where and it is
it's really i'm glad in hindsight i'm
glad i've done it because now i feel
like i have a good handle and approach
on those but those are really difficult
scenes
and so two pages with 12 actors is
harder than 10 pages with two actors
so that so it's an interesting added
dynamic it's like exponentially more
difficult for every additional character
that's in a room unless you have a
director
uh who's very intentional like sure sure
there are sure there are 11 people in
here but only this person matters and
when they have
the the fortitude to just stick with
that and actually all we really need is
a shot that pushes in here and maybe a
wide or that's great
but usually everybody wants to cover
their butt and so they're like well
we're going to need a close-up here and
close up and they
generally people which bums me out but
they every line of dialogue that's
spoken by anybody they're like well we
have to get that in this shot it's like
you don't have to actually and most of
the great filmmakers don't bother with
that it's it's again it's intention it's
what's the scene about it's not about
every person
hopefully though sometimes it is uh it's
it's usually focused in on one or two
people their dynamic and you're trying
to capture that and so you let that lead
your decisions
but yeah if it's if it's a high number
of pages that you're shooting per day
uh
it's
challenging it's really hard and i i do
not enjoy it the lower the number of
pages i mean it's similar to setups
if if it's fewer pages they're going to
be
shot better they're going to be it's
going to be more cinematic or more
intentional
and if it's a high page count
i hope i get another job offer then
because it's it's tough it's exhausting
and you and it really the really what
gets sacrificed first is uh the light
your light you just can't you can't
shape the light as much because you need
to look generally so many different
directions and so it's a lot trickier to
be intentional about your lighting
how many times do you read a screenplay
before you step on set that's a really
good question
whenever yeah it's funny whenever i
start a new project and uh and it's you
know i get this the script
i always think i'm gonna read it a
million times i think i'm gonna read it
every night
and inevitably
other things come my way and i end up
not reading it as many times as i want
but that said
i read scenes so i won't read it
beginning to end that many times you
know a few times certainly right at the
beginning
um but then it's re really becomes
it very quickly turns into a puzzle so
it's almost like you're given the puzzle
all as a finished piece
and then almost immediately you break it
up and then it's little puzzle pieces
and you're like okay this one we're
gonna do on day 17 this one and you
almost separate it out
and so it
and so i'll read the scenes a number of
times but as a whole
i might not revisit it
again
it's very it's strange but also in tv
there are rewrites happening all the
time so you have to reread because there
are new drafts coming and sometimes this
has not happened much but it has
happened
where there's a rewrite that happens and
you're in week
nine
and there's a rewrite and
i will have missed an email or something
and i won't realize
and will be on set and like oh this is
where they walk out to the kitchen
you're like no no no they go to sleep i
remember this and like no no in the
rewrite now it goes and you're like oh
no like i didn't and so you scramble and
it sucks when that happens but it does
happen tv and different shows you know
some shows are rewriting
as you're on set i mean pen 15
has a lot of improv which is a little
different but they will improvise
and as we're doing it they'll we'll
realize oh this affects a scene that we
have to shoot next week or this affects
a scene we've already shot
so the whole thing does need to be in my
head pretty well
so it's
i guess the answer is i never read it
enough
um i always think i'm going to read it
more
but it's always close i'm always if i
have a minute
especially on the day the morning of i
reread the scenes that we're shooting
for the day for sure to refresh but then
i also try to look at for every scene
that you're shooting you look to either
side of it like where did we just come
out of and then what are we going back
into because that affects your first and
last shot in a sequence too
because you want it to you don't want it
to be jarring when it cuts to the next
thing so you're trying to hold a lot in
your mind
do you take any notes or storyboard when
you're going through a script
yeah i don't storyboard when i'm reading
a script um but i do take notes i take a
lot of notes on but it's it's especially
at the beginning it's very loose it it's
whatever occurs to me like sometimes
that's an actual shot i'll write down oh
slow zoom in
or big wide or you know what whatever
whatever that is or get a close-up of
the scissors anything whatever that for
what if it strikes me
but
um
often and sometimes it's it's something
a little broader like um oh handheld
maybe this is a handheld moment or maybe
this is static or maybe
some it's rare
at the beginning but sometimes like a
color might occur to me
something really i'll let myself jot
down anything and then i'll let future
me
decide if that's relevant or not
but i do take notes um i don't
storyboard and i have rarely worked with
directors who storyboard unless it's a
commercial because it's so much smaller
it's much easier
or if there's a difficult sequence
difficult can be
maybe it's an action sequence
um or it's just
you know
like let's say four people in a car can
get very confusing and so sometimes i'll
have directors who will storyboard
because they want to make sure like oh
this and like that everything's kind of
intentional um but usually it's shot
lists and so it'll be a list of like you
know wide medium close-up on her we need
to zoom for this moment and it's a list
and that's kind of your guide and your
map and very often
uh
that all changes on the day maybe
because an actor goes a certain way or
maybe because you have a new idea but
having that plan
goes a long way and even if you never
use a single shot it means you know
because there are going to be days where
you're not feeling it where you're not
like you're just whatever the actors are
out of it or the directors out of it or
i'm out of it
and then you know you have something to
fall back on that will still work like
this is still going to this is this is
still a recipe that in the end you have
a scene
so i think it's really important to have
that really important to plan and talk
that out but then on the day
always being ready
for something better and or if just
something changes dramatically you lose
a location or whatever
i think being able to to improvise is
really valuable
do you come up with your own shot list
or do you always leave that up to the
director
generally the director brings a shot
list um
very often we do that together that's
the ideal is that a director and i
um
the really the best what i find is is
the best way it's just generally not
practical is to be able to go with the
director to a location
and be up on your feet and actually like
walk around use the phone as a little
like take pictures we'll do that
[Music]
that is
that's the ideal
rarely do you have time to go ahead of
time with a director to a location
usually you have to pay for locations
whenever you're there so
um
but yeah generally it's with a director
you
sit through each scene and you talk it
out and you're kind of imagining
how
you know actors might move in the space
and what moments do you need
but sometimes the director will just
come with their own shot list that
they've done on their own and then i
look through it we talk through it maybe
i have suggestions
really where i uh i think one of the
strengths that i have is
on the day because you're always
battling time
is
watching the directors and actors walk
through a scene
when i can see it up on its feet
i can often figure out a way to combine
two or three shots into one like oh if
she starts here and then she walks to
there and i slide the camera here then
we'll actually get
both of those shots on your list like
that's
that's something that
i think is very helpful
for time but also
you know trying to cut down on the
number of shots just for for
you know to try and control the edit a
little bit to tell the story uh again
with intention
is that it's like well instead of just
get putting the camera here and then
putting it here and putting it here and
putting it here it's like maybe we can
travel maybe this actor's move can pull
the camera and now you're in a new setup
that gets you this other thing that you
you wanted
so but it's a it's a combination for
sure and different directors some are
better at shot listings some are worse
some hate it some love it
and so i have to be kind of
amenable to all of that
how much do you plan out the day before
your shoot the ideal is that
every day
is very well planned out uh and
that doesn't mean it won't change
because it will change but
the ideal is that way now that said
uh
sometimes working on series
you don't get time to prep with the
directors some directors come in and
let's say they're doing episodes four
and five
and they you know you've hopefully met
them but even sometimes
you're meeting them on the day and
they're coming in and they've done their
own prep that's separate from you
and you try to do your best to work with
them and i know on bigger shows
that happens a lot like the csi's of the
world
directors come in and out and they don't
get a lot of time with their
cinematographers and that's that's got
to be scary that has to be very
challenging
i've been lucky enough that that's rare
for me usually i get some time with them
but
uh very often
they will a director will come in with a
plan that i have never seen before and
then i will
depending on their comfort level um i
will try and make that fit like our
location a little more or the feel of
the show because i've been shooting it
for a while so i'm like oh normally we
won't
zoom here or whatever that is
so it's yeah it varies
and it's it's
and then there are i have worked with
directors where there we just
have a good rhythm and we just kind of
wing it you know like we we show up on
the day and i'm pretty good at
if i have actors and a director and all
that i can figure out
what shots
create a scene for sure
so
but that's taken years of shooting shows
for sure but at this point i feel pretty
comfortable with that
how do you know an actor is the real
deal i suppose
like anything
uh there are many different ways
for actors to be you know quote unquote
good or bad
and you know i think you can
i've started to think about them a
little bit like athletes
and
you know some work harder than others
some have some natural talent
but there are also
specialty
kind of approaches like
uh
let's say like a
a quirky actor you know like a specialty
three-point shooter it doesn't mean that
this person is good at all the things
but cast correctly casting i guess is
really part of it
uh
if they're in the right spot you put
them in a position to succeed so one
person can really shine
if they're in the right role and it's a
well-written role of course
whereas that same person you could see
on a different set on a different day in
a different role and you're like oh i
don't know about that like it's
so
there are a number of factors that said
every once in a while and i would not
know how to to quantify it but every
once in a while i find myself
behind the camera and i'm watching
something i'm like oh this person's
gonna be around forever like you there's
just something
um
you know i mean i guess back in the day
you would think of that like oh they've
got it
you know i
i hesitate to put it that way but that
said i have seen that i've seen actors
were like oh like that's me i had i had
the good fortune of working with um
matt damon on on a tiny little like a
youtube thing
i watched george clooney work
and
they are so prepared
and so comfortable there's like a
confidence that they carry with them
they treated everybody around them
phenomenally well they were very loose
but then when it came to time to work
they could snap right in you could tell
they had done the work
so all
all of this stuff whereas other actors
come they don't know their lines
and so i think part of it is just
preparation truly
and
on set that comes across as like wow
they're really talented but really it's
just that they put in the work
uh so i think that's part of it but
you know i i often find myself surprised
when i'm on set and
it's time to do a scene and this
person's been around and then all of a
sudden
the camera's rolling and this like they
morph into something else so i don't
know where some of these things come
from
i know some of it is work it's prep
but some of it that maybe there is just
a natural thing i don't know i don't
know it's a little bit of magic i think
i don't know i i continue to wonder the
same thing
yeah
what other qualities are you looking for
in an actor you know
it's interesting so for me because i
have no power over choosing an actor
in my position as a cinematographer the
actors are
chosen so
whoever's there
like i'm gonna do
whatever i can do with them
there are little treats that some actors
bring
there are some actors who
just physically their eyes will catch a
light really well they have like big or
big brown eyes let's say and they're
just almost no matter where they are
they'll always catch a little bit of
light and then some actors their eyes
are a little like deeper i think i have
kind of smallish eyes and it can get
tricky because like an eye light can go
a long way
when you're lighting somebody in terms
of creating an empathy there's something
really magical about an ilite and
some actors it's hard to get the
eyelight you're like trying to find the
spot and some of them won't take it so i
mean that's a
that's a purely physical thing that they
have no control over so there are like
treats like that sometimes i'm like oh
this and you know skin tones different
actors they have you're just like oh
this like takes the the the warmth
really well so there are little things
like that
but a um
i mean i guess as with most people on a
set there really is
to somebody being
um
kind and professional being prepared
that's a actually
preparation is maybe one of the biggest
things because
we i've a number of times in my life we
i have with the director we plan this
shot where oh they're going to take them
out the door we're going to dolly all
the way down and then they sit here and
then they're going to interact with this
person and get in their car and go
and then the actor can't get through
their lines and you have to
reapproach the entire scene and do it
because somebody doesn't know their
lines
and sometimes that's hard because they
have a ton of lines and that's brutal i
wouldn't be able to do that but
sometimes it's a lack of preparation
so i guess
yeah i suppose for all the all the
random things i just named
i want a prepared actor somebody is
taking it seriously because like
it it affects
my ability to do a good job if somebody
comes in unprepared so i think something
as basic as that is
about all you can ask from somebody is
don't be a dick and be prepared
that's that goes a long way
so if someone is not prepared then
you're doing numerous retakes people are
reading them their lines
it's constant yeah there's there's
constant like you have to reset you have
to take it all in pieces and if they can
only get a few lines at a time it means
you have to cut to something else
because in the edit you need when
they're when they're resetting you have
to cut so it's forcing your hand
in an edit and you have to rethink the
way you're building a scene which can
mean this is not the way we intended or
this isn't this isn't going to feel the
way we want this to feel uh but you have
to you know because and and look
i say that as though it's really easy
that you know you're doing a shoot
especially
if there's you know one or two lead
characters
and they have to memorize lines for 15
weeks
every day and scripts are being
rewritten it is a big ask that is a big
load that these actors are carrying like
it really i empathize with them it's
really hard acting is i know we all tend
to think of it as like oh celebrity and
you're famous here
it is brutal it is hard work especially
if you're on a tv show
scripts are changing you have tons of
dialogue and then on top of that you
have all these people whispering in your
ear i have to gauge
when
we do it let's say we're shooting a
scene and an actor
you know on top of all their lines maybe
a director gives them dire oh no this
part don't forget you need to be sad in
this little thing but then come back up
but then for me i maybe need an actor to
land in a certain spot and maybe they
haven't
and i will have to gauge
going back to reading the room
if they seem overwhelmed
i won't give them that note on the first
take i will like let them get a little
more comfortable and then if i can do
anything on my side to adjust maybe we
tweak a light maybe i move my camera
then i'll do that otherwise i'm waiting
until they're comfortable and then as
gently as i can just like hey don't
forget like after you get up from the
dinner table i need you to land in this
area and i have to be very careful
because
i am
lower priority you want the performance
to to work if the performance doesn't
work it doesn't matter how pretty my
light is
you want the performance to lead so for
me
i have to make sure an actor is
comfortable
and that they feel comfortable with me
and then gauging when they're too
overwhelmed or it's okay now to give
them a no or sometimes you know some
directors
prefer me to give notes sometimes i go
to the director and i say hey you need
to remind them that they have to get to
this area and things like that so there
are lots of little things that actors
are constantly being bombarded with it's
it's
so i think for for a cinematographer
or a camera operator uh it's really
important to have empathy and realize
that these actors even if you don't like
them
they are carrying a lot and you need to
protect them and their space their
headspace and the physical space that
you're working in
yeah that's why i always and i've said
this numerous times when people say oh
well so-and-so doesn't want to hang out
in between takes and they just go back
into their dressing room but i think
that they would need that time oh man i
would not i would definitely not hang
out in between takes like there's no way
there's just so much and people you know
especially if um an actor has any kind
of celebrity people get a little you
know googly eyed and a little and they
want to interact they want to be able to
go home to their spouse and just be like
you know i was talking with george
clooney about chicken today
but
they are there's so much going on for
them so i do my best to like just stay
out of their way
because there's there's really a lot of
people are really pulling at actors
attentions same with directors too but
they don't have usually that celebrity
attached and people get
you know people get weird around
celebrity unfortunately
how do you know if a director is the
real deal he had directors are
directors are kind of the the biggest
wild card uh on a set in terms of well
it's close between actors and directors
but
a director dictates so much of how a job
goes for me um it's a bit and it's a big
part of why i will say yes or no to a
job for sure is the director uh
boy
well i think going back to something we
talked about earlier is i need to feel
engaged
and creatively engaged and
if
i'm not it might not be the right job
for me
and the directors usually who dictates
that and because and sometimes that's
because they want a ton of control
sometimes it's because they don't know
what they want at all
um
or maybe their aesthetic is
very different from mine
uh so i don't know that i'd think of it
as like a good or a bad director
it's more about like a
match it's i mean it's almost like a
romantic partnership you know it doesn't
mean
if you if you are dating somebody it
doesn't mean
it's that they are good or bad it's just
how well do you mesh with them how how
are your
how does your communication work what is
your taste
what are you trying to get to when
you're working on something so i
it really does feel like a romantic
partnership in a way because it's it's
pretty intimate and you are relying on
each other and you're going to be around
each other in
very stressful situations when you're
tired you're hungry
you know things aren't working out how
do you react how do they react
and can you and i've been very fortunate
i i've i get along with most of the
directors i work with
but i absolutely have had directors that
i can tell
like
aren't very fond of because there's you
know my own joy and happiness and
sometimes the project itself that can
only bring so much joy or happiness but
the the there are directors that like
i'm like oh this just isn't
isn't going great like it's just not
working out and i and i do think my job
is to serve them for the most part and
so i try to do my best but it doesn't
always work
but it yeah it's it's i don't know
there's a weird
chemistry you try to gauge up front as
best you can will this be a good match
but
you know until you're in the trenches
with somebody you don't know how it'll
be
what's the mark of a professional
a professional director that maybe a
newer director someone a little more
green
won't have as many traits or practices
habits
yeah
you know
directing such an interesting one
there's a there's a
joke that you'll hear sometimes on set
like who
has the least amount of experience on a
set and
almost always it's the director
it's it's just the nature of getting to
a directing position can be very that
you know
sometimes it's who you know sometimes
you wrote a script and you're being you
know
who knows and
i think one of the things that's
that has to be the most challenging for
a new director or an inexperienced
director
is there's this big machine moving
and at this point for somebody like me
like i have a lot more to learn but i've
been doing it for a long time and so
when we're looking at a scene and an
actor's like oh i actually i don't want
to sit here i want to get up and i want
to go by the
stand by the window
is for some directors that might freak
them out completely
they because they they don't know
they've made a plan and then as soon as
something breaks in the plan be that an
actor's decision or
maybe bad weather or a location falls
through or there's an equipment
malfunction is the ability to
change and still you know whatever that
intention of the scene is is that you
can still find it but using none of what
you planned
and i think for a newer director that's
got to be so hard is finding you know
for me
one of the things i'm good at is uh
i think i'm good at at least is
sequencing like in a scene it's like
okay well we don't need this close-up
because we're going to come around and
when that when she walks through here
this shot will land so we'll have that
line dialogue here and then we need to
be cam shooting or like i can very
quickly
piece together
like okay
this is all the okay yeah we'll have all
the pieces and a lot of directors can't
do that they they just just simply by
because of you know not being not having
shot as much um so it doesn't mean
necessarily good or bad
but that ability to think on your feet i
think is one of the most valuable things
especially for tv because it's so fast
paced or lower budget feature you you
just can't stop you have to go go
and
i think that's probably
probably one of the biggest things and
and i don't know
i don't know how to like advise a
director exactly because some of it is
just hours just putting in just doing it
doing it more and
learning so you know so i guess going
back to similar to my job or an actor's
job is preparation
is knowing that they know
what a scene or a whole piece needs to
feel like or be like
and then
the ability to improvise i guess if
you're too rigid
and then something falls apart
will you be able to adjust i guess
that's
and maybe not and maybe you know there
are directors like david fincher who are
just like he is going to get what he
wants the way he wants it you know so
it's not like being precise is wrong
it's just on the
shows i've been on
you can't like you can't get everything
perfectly and so how do you still make
it work
yeah
generally speaking what's an appropriate
amount of time a director should give a
cinematographer to light a scene
uh
you know
in terms of time to light a scene
there's definitely no
answer because so like no no strict
answer because it all depends on the
size of a shoot
um
and maybe the better way to think about
it is
how much time
do you need do they do the actors need
because you the more time i take
to light the less time actors have to
act the fewer takes a director gets to
direct
so that's all part of the factor and
then also
how many scenes you have that day
you know if you're in one location for
the day
and
it's one time of day one mood
then i can take a lot more time
at the beginning of the day
because we're never moving but if we
have to do three location moves that day
we need to we need to start shooting as
soon as possible so it's kind of a big
math problem
because i could light a scene
for two years like there's no such thing
as like okay i'm done now it's perfect i
could go forever and so
the things that caused me to be like all
right it's good enough or whatever is
what else is in play and and you know
there's an ad somewhere nearby that is
like hey are you done like there's
somebody
generally around but
it really depends on the scale because
you know if you
you can light a scene
with no lights if you do the right time
of day in the right location that that's
it you just if you plan it out you're
like if we are here at 7 30
and the camera's ready to go we need to
shoot at 7 30 because by 8 30 the
light's no good anymore and then we have
to come in and supplement it and that'll
take a whole hour or whatever so so
every scene is a little different
um
you definitely fall into rhythms uh you
know last show i shot
um
the beginning of the day is always
slower because people are unloading
equipment and all that
but
we would block through a scene and then
you know i talked to the director and
the a.d and i i'll we'll kind of run
through okay we need seven shots for
this scene and i'll be like okay well
this side i need
40 minutes let's say to light this but
then we have a turn around and i need to
reset the light for that and so that
means that's going to be another maybe
20 minutes and so it's every scene
every day every location every shot is
kind of its own animal honestly so it's
you have to be constantly thinking about
that but
it's yeah it just varies
anywhere from zero minutes to
you know a day of lighting truthfully
like it could it can really be anywhere
in between
have you been on set where it's been
you know six hours worth of lighting one
shot
well so there are scenes if there is a
scene
uh where
for instance
like a long
one or like a steady cam that goes
through a restaurant we did that on my
last show there's a steadicam shot that
starts in a parking lot it comes into a
restaurant goes in through the kitchen
back out through the rest of the
restaurant into another room where then
there's a whole family waiting for them
so
i don't so what we did is we basically
lit the whole restaurant and the outdoor
parking lot
and that took
i mean
i don't remember but it's probably half
a day
but
then it meant that we were mostly lit so
not only did we do that steadicam shot
but then you jump into doing your
dialogue scenes and the light you kind
of you sort of light 360. and so in
theory you can point any direction
and you can shoot now ideally you are
able to tweak this and that
but um yeah for if you if you can
capture
a lot of material or light a whole space
that's something i try to do when i can
is lighting a space uh a little more
because then it allows you like okay
we've gotten these shots but now we bump
in here we don't need to tweak the light
oh we turn here we don't need to tweak
the light now that's hard uh and it's
hard to make look good but
that is
that is one way of approaching it so a
lot more time up front but then you just
crank
how do you decide when to move the
camera and when not to move the camera
yeah moving the camera is it's
interesting because and and often the
director and i will discuss you know in
pre-production because some
um some directors or projects
want uh constant movement that maybe
it's like a light float but that it's
just always
moving in some capacity
and then
on other projects or other directors
it's like no
only moves
when it's a very specific and important
beat uh
i've had shows where we didn't move the
camera period and i've had shows where
it's never still and so it really just
it so depends on the project and the
director really because some of it's
just taste and you know i will have my
own
takes on it like if i feel like well
moving in this scene this is such a this
this character is really sad and
if the camera's moving around it's going
to feel too sexy or too exciting and
maybe because it's always moving maybe
now it being static is going to
accentuate that because we're used to it
moving and vice versa so context really
dictates all of it but you do want there
to be a reason not
even if it's a show where everything's
moving
why is it always moving you don't like
it's tricky when
when the reason is
oh it's just cool like it's it's not
that that's wrong there's no right or
wrong but for me again
thoughtfulness is so important to me
like why are things happening and if the
reason is because it's cool like
that's not wrong you know it's just less
exciting it's harder for me to sink my
teeth into that and i think uh i can get
lazy i get you know if it's just like
well there's no i'm just kind of sliding
the camera around then
i
if i'm not thinking about what i'm doing
uh
you know by by day three just like what
what am i doing here
so
so it's it's tricky but you know you
want you want
traveling with like
something that david fincher going back
to finches something he does
because he's he's a his style of
filmmaking
freaks me out a little bit because it's
so controlled and i get nervous like
would i even be able to survive a david
fincher shoot i don't know
but his camera tends to lock into actors
if actors are moving the camera's moving
and they're in sync and
that's pretty impressive like when
somebody's getting up and sitting down
the camera but that takes
you know he does 100 takes of stuff like
it
that's hard that's really hard work uh
but that's an approach that makes sense
is if actor moves camera moves factors
still cameras still uh but there is just
you know there is everywhere i mean a
michael bay thing camera's always alive
but that's because he wants it all to be
a roller coaster ride and so it's not
again it's not wrong it's just like
that's the that's the aesthetic so i
guess it starts from
a vision
and then hopefully
the camera's movement or lack thereof
at least there's like a string
connecting it to that original vision
and again intention
did you see uncut gems it did yes that's
it yeah uncut gems constantly moving
camera which makes that that character
is constantly moving so yeah that's a
perfect example of something that like
there's a reason for that and then it's
just like go go go because it's a
whirlwind his whole life is a whirlwind
yeah especially in the jewelry store or
out on the street yeah it was just
constant and and and
i think it works so well for that film
and it was it really conveyed who he was
as a character what his world was like
yeah that's actually a much better
example because i know michael bay
brings a lot of like people have a lot
of associations but uncut gems is a
great example of constant camera
movement for a reason and very effective
it feels very chaotic
yeah that's great
what tools or equipment should a
beginning cinematographer buy
early because they're going to be using
them all the time that's a good question
i think you know
if you can get a fast lens
i think that is a very useful tool a
lens that can you know opens up to
at least a two let's say well i'd say
two eight is a good minimum but if you
can get something like these rokinons i
mentioned those are a 1.5 or something
uh
i think a fastlands is a very valuable
tool for a couple reasons one you can
shoot in lower light situations so just
just helps when you don't have a lot of
gear but also it can teach you
about
depth of field because you can get to
the extreme and you can see what a very
shallow depth of field can do for you
which but also a deep depth of field so
i think that's one of the i would
probably start there
and then beyond
that you know i think it's it's getting
easier now but like a strong light but
those are hard to find cheap but a
strong light source i've noticed
if you can have a strong light source
coming in a window
it gives you such a great baseline to
start from but usually a bigger light is
something that requires a bigger crew
and more money so that's maybe a little
more wishful thinking
uh
there's an app called sun seeker and i
think there are a couple other versions
but it can tell you
you know uh
where the sun will be at any time of day
on any day of the year
and if you can really choose those spots
i use it for 100 of the spot unless i'm
in a
set where there are no windows
i want to know where the sun is going to
be and when and then i'm going to use
that to decide what direction we face
and what time of day we want to shoot
there so i think that that's an
indispensable tool as far as i'm
concerned it's kind of expensive but
i think it's it's it's worth its weight
in gold and actually along those lines
there's an app called artemis
which you can put in any camera and any
set of lenses
and it will
ingest that and then you can take it you
can be like oh i want to see on an alexa
mini 50 millimeter from this position
that's what this will look like oh
actually no we're shooting a different
camera it's going to be a black magic
it's going to be the 6k pocket cam and
we only have a 40 millimeter you plug it
in and same thing
so you can really get a sense of what
each lens is going to show you in a
space so i think those are those are i
mean i use
both of those tools
constantly on every set i've been on for
sure
so i think those are huge
um
yeah i think those are those would be
the big ones
anything maybe hold off on it's not as
necessary
i you know i think we have
um we all have obsessions with
cameras like camera brands and
i think nowadays especially
uh
what you can get with a 1 000 camera
blows my mind
and i think
you know there are benefits to cameras
like an alexa or
red or whatever they all have they all
have their advantages but uh
not feeling like you have to get a
high-end camera to shoot a high-end
image
that is
not the case anymore i would say
one thing if your camera does not have
internal nd filters neutral density
filters one piece of gear
that i think you do need are neutral
density filters and they have nowadays a
bunch of different brands of
variable nds and that's something that
you can screw on to the end of a lens
and you can twist it and it will
allow more or less light into your
camera
and there are a number of reasons that
that's beneficial but
it allows you to start being conscious
about shooting at certain f-stops it
gives you control so like shooting um
you know i've shot shows where we're
really opening up and it's a shallower
depth of field a little aimed more
toward beauty and you're shooting at
like a a two or for a lot of it but then
there are other times where i'm like no
we're gonna shoot at a four and it's
deeper depth of field and it feels
different
but you
you don't have that control unless you
have a neutral density filter so that's
something to get
um but in terms of yes
i think not obsessing about
quality
of your camera i think that's something
that we all get hung up on
but
the the what you can get now is it just
boggles my mind it's unbelievable so i
think the
this the floor
has
come up so high in terms of the floor of
your image is always going to be pretty
good now in terms of what the camera can
give you at least
so yeah not obsessing about
an expensive camera is probably a big
thing
can you dispel the myth can you really
fix it in post
i hate fixing it in post i am not a
believer in fixing it in post for one
it will often not get fixed in post
because just like in production when you
run out of time and money
people run out of time and money and
post and so a lot of things end up just
getting tossed by the wayside
and you know it's important to know
when
you can
fix something if you're you know you're
on set and you're running out of time
and you're you're the sun is going down
it's like well we're almost out of light
but we can still shoot this but in post
they're gonna have to pull it up it's
not gonna look as good but you know the
range it's like we can get it to a
certain so sometimes out of necessity
but i i hate fixing it in post i
i think it's
when you start hearing that which you
will hear all the time and i will say it
sometimes
but that should never be
where you land if you don't have to and
then when you have to that's the beauty
you can do so much in post these days
but
you shouldn't set out with that as your
initial attitude for sure
you've been asked to do a commencement
speech at a college
what are your final words to
young cinematographers
upcoming generation of filmmakers
cinematographers
you yeah you know i never would have
guessed this and i i touched on this
earlier but
coming into this industry i never would
have guessed how far
kindness can get you being pleasant to
work with
people are
i've gotten i don't know what other
cinematographers do but a lot of them
apparently it's not good because the
amount of times that different
departments specifically art department
but
and sound and costume that will come up
to me and i'm not i'm not mother teresa
i'm just a normal person the amount of
times that departments come up to me
like andy you're so nice i love working
with you
it feels like they've been abused
puppies
that somebody's now giving them a
biscuit like i'm not
so
for me and i same with producers i've
had producers
tell me outright that the reason that
they rehire me is because of the
atmosphere i create on set not the
visual atmosphere just the vibe
and
i
never would have thought that that would
get me work that never even occurred to
me
i'm thankful that that's true it's it's
been good for my career
but
i think
remembering that
this is your life like the way you spend
your day today
is your life and when you're on set
if you suck to be around if you're
unpleasant to be around that is not
gonna serve you
and
what an amazing gift that being nice and
happy
can be good for your career like that
that feels too good to be true but
that's exactly what i've found and so i
think embracing film has opened me up as
a person got me to be more confident
less shy because i love it so much
and if it's also teaching me to meditate
and be kinder i never yell i never ever
yell on set i want to yell
but i don't it's teaching me to like
control my emotions don't blow up be
patient
that's i i just it it brings me so much
joy to think that being better at my
career makes me a better person and
being a better person makes me better at
my career so i would think
that's the best piece of advice is allow
your goodness as a person
to help you be a better craftsman better
to work with everybody wants that i
would assume in every field
you said you went on some road trips um
after 2009 you know you kind of
you know you you didn't really have that
much weighing you down and what did you
see on some of these road trips
yeah i i'm the big there was some quote
that somebody once told me that akira
kurosawa said and then i've tried to
find it and i've never found it so i
have no idea somebody just said it to me
but
to be a good filmmaker live an
interesting life
and
i spent
a good chunk of my late 20s and early
30s
living a weird life
on the road i was traveling i slept on
couches i slept in cars i slept on the
ground like i was
i was adventuring i was i was living a
life and i was
looking at the world around me like
literally just looking at the world
part of that is looking at light but
part of that seeing
you know
mountains in the snow versus desert in
in the summer versus
you know the seeing an ocean a quiet
lake a busy city
these all have a feeling to them and
emotion and
having that experience you never know
what kind of script will come your way
and what you'll be able to touch on
and then ultimately
people
is to to connect with strangers a
stranger on a bus in the middle of italy
or you know wherever to to connect with
different people or just watching people
i think that just gives you
it gives you a richer life which then
gives you a richer palette to pull from
when you're coming up with ideas so i i
really am a big bully now i do wonder
sometimes had i maybe started my career
a little earlier
would i be further along now
but
what i did in my late 20s early 30s this
kind of vagabond life
was interesting and i would imagine it's
painted by experience which i bring to
my work for sure so i think making sure
i'm a huge film nerd but
living some life outside of movies i
think is a very valuable thing you know
connect with the world around you as
best you can